ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE TO
ORDER I'M GOING TO READ A FEW
INSTRUCTIONS FIRST. WE ARE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- TWO OR HAVING A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING. IT EVEN THOUGH THIS IS
THE LARGEST HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW
MEMBERS AND SO YOU CAN SEE WE
HAVE MEMBERS. WHO ARE OFF THE
DAIS AS WELL AND AROUND THE
HEARING ROOM BUT WE ARE HAVING
A PHYSICALLY DISTANT HEARING
AND WE HAVE A FULL HEARING ROOM.
WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
WE HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND WE'RE ASKING IF
ANY PUBLIC IS HERE THAT THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO EXIT THE
ROOM AFTER THE MAY COMMENT IF
THEY SO CHOOSE. THE PANELISTS
ON THE AGENDA ARE APPEARING
REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. AND BECAUSE THIS IS
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
MEMBERS MAY HAVE REQUESTED IN
ADVANCE TO APPEAR REMOTELY-
THERE WILL BE NO VOTE IN
COMMITTEE TODAY. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE PHONE LINE. THAT NUMBER
WILL BE SHOWN AS WERE STREAMING
ONLINE BUT THE NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR TWO OH TO. GIVE ANY
PROBLEMS REACHING THE- PHONE
LINE YOU CAN CALL OUR ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE NINE. SO TODAY'S HEARING
COVERS TWO BILLS SB EIGHTY NINE
S. B. NINETY ONE SB EIGHTY NINE
IS A BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AND SB
NINETY ONE IS A BUDGET TRAILER
BILL. THE STATE'S CURRENT
EVICTION MORATORIUM AS WE ALL
KNOW EXPIRES ON THE SUNDAY
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST. WE KNOW
THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
DEVASTATE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO CANNOT PAY
RENT THEY WILL BE FORCED-
POTENTIALLY OUT OF THEIR HOMES.
WE WANTED TO ENSURE THAT WE
TOOK ACTION TO MOVE THE TWO
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS FROM
FEDERAL AID THAT WE RECEIVE BUT
ALSO TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXTEND OUR MORATORIUM. LET ME
JUST IN PARTICULAR I THINK THE
YOU KNOW LEADERSHIP FROM OUR
SPEAKER I KNOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
CHIU AND RARE STOP MAJORITY
LEADER RAY S. AS WELL AS A
MEMBER STONE. WE'RE VERY
CRITICAL IN THIS- HOUSES
DELIBERATION OVER THE OBJECTION
MORATORIUM EXPANSION BUT WE
THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
IN ORDER TO KEEP PEOPLE IN
THEIR HOMES DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. AT THE SAME TIME WE
KNOW THAT THEIR MANY MOM AND
POP LANDLORDS WHO. HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO STAY AFLOAT AS THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN GETTING ANY RENT.
SO JUST IN TERMS OF A YOU KNOW
JUST IN TERMS OF HOUSEKEEPING
WE'VE GOT TO PERMIT FINEST
PRESENT BOTH BILLS TOGETHER
FOLLOWED BY COMMENTS FROM LA-
OTHER MEMBERS OF- FINANCE AS
WELL AS AGENCY OR I WILL STOP
ARE AVAILABLE AND THEN WE'LL
MOVE TO MEMBERS QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS I WAS JUST GOING TO
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS FROM DIFFERENT MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ARE LOOKING
FOR NEW VICE CHAIR MISTER FOX.
I THINK MISTER CHAIR- YOU KNOW
WE CERTAINLY ARE HERE TO. HELP
A GROUP OF BUT HELP EVERY GROUP
OF CALIFORNIANS GET OUT THIS
PANDEMIC- GET BACK TO WORK THE
OPENER ECONOMY I GET KIDS BACK
INTO SCHOOL INTO THE AND I
FULLY APPRECIATE THE URGENCY OF
THIS SITUATION THAT WE'RE IN.
AND WE MUST TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO PROVIDE RELIEF TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS I WILL ADMIT. THAT
THE PROCESS WE'RE DEALING WITH
IS FRUSTRATING AND NOT JUST
MYSELF AND TO SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES- BUT TO THE PUBLIC
OUTSIDE HIS BUILDING LOOKING TO
US. TO GOVERN SO THE PROCESS
ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO BE BETTER
AS OF THE MEASURES LIKE THESE-
BEFORE US CANNOT BE PROPERLY
CONSIDERED. YEAH I DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND WHAT IT'S DONE
AND AN ASSORTMENT OF TIME THAT
WE HAVE HAD SINCE YOU'VE BEEN
SESSION. I LOOK FORWARD TO A
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION TODAY.
THE TICKET WAS FROM ANY OTHER
MEMBER. ONE OF MAKE OPENING
COME. ABSOLUTELY SO THEN LET'S
LET'S START WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FIRST AND THEY WERE
GONNA GO TO EL AL AND I BELIEVE
IT'S- MISS ERIKA LEE WHO'S HERE
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
MY UNDERSTANDING IS MISLI ONCE
YOU START TALKING YOU SHOULD
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN JUST MAKE
SURE YOU AND YOURSELF. I CAN
MORNING THERE YOU GO WE HEAR
YOU WE'RE GOING TO SO I HOPE
WE'LL SEE YOU THERE YOU GO
PERFECT LOOKING. OKAY. I'M GOOD
MORNING TERRY TANG VICE CHAIR
FONG MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ERICA LANE APARTMENT NO
FINANCED. TODAY I WILL BE
PRESENTING- SB EIGHTY NINE A
BUDGET BILL. WHICH AMENDS THE
CURRENT BUDGET SB NINETY ONE A
TRAILER BILL WHICH EXTENDS THE
STATE'S EVICTION MORATORIUM.
AND CREATES A STATE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ALLOCATE
FEDERAL RENTAL AND LANDLORDS
EARLY. I'M SB NINE BUDGET BILL
IS FAIRLY SHORT IT CONSISTS OF
TECHNICAL ITEMS- SB EIGHTY NINE
ADDS TO TECHNICAL ITEMS TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT TO
PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. OR HDD AS I RECALL
IT THE NECESSARY AUTHORITIES
AND FLEXIBILITIES TO IMPLEMENT
AND ADMINISTER THE FEDERAL
FUNDS ALLOCATED TO CALIFORNIA
UNDER THE RECENT FEDERAL
QUICKLY FELL. THE FEDERAL
LEGISLATION THESE TECHNICAL
BUDGET ITEMS AUTHORIZES HCD TO
TRANSFER AND USE UP 210% OF THE
FUNDS PROVIDED. TO MINISTER THE
PROGRAM. I'M THAT'S SB EIGHTY
NINE OUT OF MOVING TESTING I DO
WANT WHICH IS THE TRAILER BILL
AND THAT INCLUDES PROVISIONS
THAT EXTEND THE STATE'S
DEPICTION MORATORIUM AS CHAIR
TEAM MENTIONED AND ESTABLISHES
A STATE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. I'M GOING BACK TO
LATE- LAST AUGUST THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH INCLUDED THE
NATION'S STRONGEST EVICTION
PROTECT PROTECTIONS. AB THIRTY
EIGHTEEN HAS PREVENTED MANY
CALIFORNIANS FROM EXPERIENCING
INFECTIONS DURING THE PANDEMIC
WHICH HAS RESULTED IN LOSSES
AND INCOME NEGATIVELY IMPACTING
BUT CALIFORNIA RENTERS AND
HOMEOWNERS. HOWEVER THE PRIMARY
PROVISIONS OF THIS LAW AGAIN AS
WAS MENTIONED WILL EXPIRE AT
THE END OF THIS MONTH. BUT NOT
BEFORE MOVING INTO THE DETAILS
OF MESQUITE NINETY ONE I WANTED
YOU TO JUST NOTE THAT AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT ALSO CHARGE THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY. WITH ARE
ENGAGING RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS
ABOUT STRATEGIES TO DIRECT
POTENTIAL FUTURE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE. AND
MANY OF THE PRINCIPLE DESIGNS
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE STATE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM- WERE
WERE INFORMED BY THE
STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH GROUP- AND
DISTRIBUTED LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
TENANT AND LANDLORD GROUPS
HOUSING DEVELOPERS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS- COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AMONG MANY OTHER
INSTITUTE AMONG AMONG OTHER
GROUPS TOTALING ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS AND
INDIVIDUALS SO I JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT. A LOT OF WHAT YOU'LL
BE HEARING SB NINETY ONE WAS.
INFORMED BY THIS GROUP. SO NOW
SB NINETY- SB A ONE PROVISION
THAT EXIST. THE STATE CURRENT
EVICTION MORATORIUM FOR TEN
THAT ARE. TO PAY RENT DO
BECAUSE AT A LATER FINANCIAL.
BY FIVE MONTHS SO FROM JANUARY
THIRTY AND JUNE. OF THIS YEAR.
TENANTS MUST CONTINUE TO PAY 5%
THEIR US OBLIGATE AS A REQUIRED
UNDER AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT-
DURING THIS TIME IF TENANTS
CONTINUE TO PAY AT LEAST THIS
AMOUNT JUNE THIRTIETH. THEY'RE
PROTECTED FROM ADDICTION FOR
ANI ANY UNPAID RENT THAT. HAS
ACCUMULATED DURING THIS GIVEN.
SB NINE ONE ALL EXPAND THE SAME
THIRTY EIGHT EIGHT AB EIGHTY
EIGHT CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
HOMEOWNERS. THAT ARE RELATED TO
MORTGAGE FORBEARANCE REQUEST.
AND IT EXTENDS THE PROHIBITION
ON COMMENCING ON ACTION IN
SMALL CLAIMS COURT. TO RECOVER
SO THE NINETEEN RENTAL DEBT- TO
AUGUST FIRST AND HERE. SO GOING
INTO THE STATE MENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM SB NINETY
ONE ESTABLISHES THIS PROGRAM
AND IT WILL ALLOCATE FEDERAL
RELIEF FUNDS THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS RECEIVED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IN TOTAL THE STATE
RECEIVED OR WILL RECEIVE TWO
POINT SIX BILLION AND ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION OF THAT IS COMING
DIRECTLY TO THE STATE ONE POINT
ONE BILLION IS ALLOCATED
DIRECTLY BY THE US TREASURY TO
JURISDICTIONS WITH POPULATIONS
GREATER THAN TWO HUNDRED. THAT
INCLUDES COUNTY. THE PROGRAM
WILL PROVIDE ELIGIBLE LANDLORDS
WITH THE MEDIA AT LEAST-
THROUGH THE PAYMENT OF 80% OF
THEIR RENTAL ARREARS. THAT WERE
ACCUMULATED IT STARTING IN
APRIL OF LAST YEAR THROUGH
MARCH OF THIS YEAR. AND IN
RETURN LANDLORDS RECEIVE
IMMEDIATE RELIEF AGREED TO
ACCEPT IT AS PAYMENT IN FULL
FORGIVING THE REMAINING RENTAL
DESK FOR THE GIVEN TIME. NOW
IT'S THE TABLE ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM- WILL ADMINISTER THE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM-
FUNDS. SORRY ACT WILL
ADMINISTER THE FUNDS THAT ARE
RECEIVED BY THE STATE THROUGH
EIGHT YOU'RE EITHER A BLOCK
GRANT ALLOCATIONS. I'M TO
JURISDICTIONS OR THROUGH A
THIRD PARTY INFLUENCERS. LARGER
JURISDICTIONS MAY RECEIVE A
DIRECT BLOCK GRANT FROM THE
STATE TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR
DIRECT ALLOCATION FROM THE US
TREASURY- WELL FUNDING FOR
SMALLER JURISDICTIONS WILL BE
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE STATE
PROGRAM RANKED. THIRD PARTY
IMPLEMENTS. AND JUST UP I WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE THIRD
PARTY ADMNISTRATOR. IN
AWARDING THE PROGRAM TO THIS IN
IMPLEMENTOR SB NINETY ONE
ESTABLISHES A NUMBER
EXPECTATIONS- INSTANTIATE
INCLUDING THAT THE VENDOR HAVE
EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
COMMUNITY LEVEL PARTNERS. AND
THIS WILL HELP INSURE ALL AREAS
IN TARGET COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING HARD TO
REACH HOUSEHOLDS- RACIAL EQUITY
IN TRADITIONALLY UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS. HAVE ACCESS TO THE
PROGRAM THAT WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT
STATEWIDE- PEOPLE- IN VARIOUS
CIRCUMSTANCES IN DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS COULD START. I'M
ALSO THE VENDOR IT MUST HAVE
THE TECHNOLOGICAL CAPACITY TO
STAND UP A SEXUAL ONLINE
APPLICATION PORTAL AND SYSTEM
THAT SERVES BOTH LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS. AND HAS MOBILE AND
MULTI LINGUAL. KEEP I'M AND I
ALSO HAVE A CAPACITY TO BE
AVAIL TWENTY HOURS A DAY SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK. AND HAD A LEVELING-
WITHOUT DISRUPTION. NEW THAT'S
ATTENTION TOP ENSURE THE OUT
REGION. AND PUBLIC AWARE OF THE
AND THEY'RE BETTER. AND RIGHTS
ON THIS. BOTH FOR LANDLORDS AND
FOR TEN. IT ALSO ENSURES
CONSISTENCY RELIABILITY AND
ACCESS. I'M IN TO ALLOCATE.
STATE FUNDING WILL BE ALLOCATED
FOR JURISDICTIONS BASED ON OUR
PROPORTIONATE SHARE POPULATION
THERE IS A SMALL COUNTY CARVE
OUT OF THE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND BE SMART
SMALLER COUNTIES- WILL HAVE
POPULATIONS UNDER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND. AND DID NOT RECEIVE
DIRECT INDIRECT ALLOCATION AS
TREASURY. LARGE JURISDICTIONS
WITH POPULATIONS ABOVE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND WILL RECEIVE
FUNDS BASED ON THEIR PERCENTAGE
ALL. THAT BOTH LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS MAY APPLY TO THE
PROGRAM PERSISTENCE THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM DOES EMPHASIZE LANDMARK
EDUCATION I'M IN CASES WHERE
LANDLORDS CHOOSE NOT TO
PARTICIPATE THE PROGRAM STILL-
THEY STILL CANNOT EVICT TENANTS
FOR NON PAYMENT OF RENT SO LONG
AS THAT TENET CONTINUES TO PAY
THE 25% OF RIGHT. THROUGH THE
TIME CARRIED UP JUNE THIRTIETH-
BUT IN THESE CASES AN ELIGIBLE
TENANT MAY APPLY TO THE PROGRAM
ON BEHALF OF THEIR LANDLORD.
AND RECEIVED 25% OF THEIR
REPAIRS THAT MUST THEN GO TO A
LOT MORE TO PAY. FOR THEIR
FRIENDS. SO RECOGNIZING THE
NEED OF COMMUNITY AND STRICT
FEDERAL REQUIRE. AROUND THESE
PLANS H. C. H. D. Y. A BLOCK
GRANT. IMMEDIATE AFTER CHURCH
JURISDICTIONS OPT INTO THE
PROGRAM. AND CONTRACTS ARE
EXECUTED. AND THEN AFTER THAT
GRANTEES MUST OBLIGATE AT LEAST
65% OF THEIR STATE FUNDED BY
JUNE FIRST. AND ALL OF THEIR
STATE FUNDS MUST BE EXPENDED BY
AUGUST FIRST. AT THAT TIME
UNUSED FUNDS WILL BE
REALLOCATED EXPANDED THROUGH
THE STATE RUN PROGRAM. NOW THE
TIMING IS THIS THAT TIMING IS
IMPORTANT AND IT'S BASED ON THE
FEDERAL TIMING WHICH BASICALLY
SAYS. THAT ALL FUNDS MUST BE
EXPENDED BY THE END OF THE
CALENDAR YEAR. AND ADDITIONALLY
ANY GRANT T. THAT HAS NOT
OBLIGATED AT LEAST 65% OF THESE
FINE. BY THE END OF SEPTEMBER
ARE AT RISK OF HAVING THESE
FUNDS CHECKING BACK- TO.
GETTING BACK TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- WHICH WOULD THEN
REALLOCATE. THE DOLLARS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. YOUR PARTNER
INTEGRITY I KIND OF. PROGRAM
FUND PROVIDE TO GRANT WILL BE
TO THE SAME RECORDING AFTER.
REQUIREMENTS AS THOSE. RIGHT IN
THE FEDERAL. AT AGE TO THE
WALL- IT INCLUDED IT IN THE
TRAILER ABOUT THE L. H. U. D.
WELL REPORT MONTHLY TO JAIL THE
SEAT FOR THE DURATION OF THE
PROGRAM SAID THE LEGISLATURE IS
AWARE OF PERFORMANCE METRICS.
AND AGAIN THIS IS OPPORTUNE
CURRENCY AND FOR COMPATIBILITY-
STATEWIDE PROGRAM AND THE
BLOCKS GRANTED FUNDS. SO IN
CLOSING THE INTENT OF THE
PROGRAM IS REALLY TO MAXIMIZE
THE IMPACT OF THE FUNDS COMING
TO CALIFORNIA I'M DOING THIS
EFFICIENTLY EQUITABLY AND
WESTCON ABILITY AND ALSO
OBVIOUSLY TO STAVE OFF
INFECTIONS AS YOU OFFER
ASSISTANCE TO TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS- WE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS I'M JOINED BY
SENIOR STAFF FROM THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES. HOUSING
AGENCY AS WELL AS COLLEAGUES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
LOOKS AT AGENCY WERE REALLY
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING TO
DEVELOP THIS PROGRAM IT'S WILL
BE ABLE TO ANSWER IN MORE
DETAIL SOME OF THE PROGRAMMATIC
QUESTIONS FOR MONTHS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SHRIMP YOU MISLI NOW
WE'RE GONNA GO. TO HELL ELSE.
GOOD MORNING FROM OHIO. IN YOUR
QUEST THAT. THEY CAN MAY HAVE
US OKAY THANK YOU MISTER WELL
WE CAN HEAR AND SEE YOU JUST
FIND GOING TO. MR CHIU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LET ME START
BY. THE THANK TO LEADERS. FROM
THE SAN FROM THE BECOME OFFICE.
FOR DEVELOPING THIS DEAL THAT
EXTENDS THE EVICTION MORATORIUM
AND GETS TWO POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS OUT QUICKLY TO
STRUGGLING TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS. INNOCENTLY I JUST
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK
OUR MAJORITY LEADER RADIUS ARE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CHAIR
STONE. FROM THE SPEAKER STAFF
MY SHOULD JACKSON AND KATIE
COOLEY CHOSE. FOR MORE HOUSING
COMMITTEE STAFF LISA ANGLE AND
SANDRA NOT GALA THESE ARE
STAFFERS THAT WORKED ROUND THE
CLOCK. TO GET THIS DONE AS WELL
AS ADVOCATES ON ALL SIDES OF
THIS ISSUE. I HAVE SAID FOR
MONTHS THAT WE HAVE TO EXTEND
THE CONVICTION MORATORIUM
BEFORE JANUARY THIRTY FIRST OR
ELSE CALIFORNIA TENANTS. ARE
STARING DOWN A VERY DARK CLIFF.
THIS IS NOT A PERFECT DEAL BUT
IT'S NECESSARY TO AVOID THAT
AFFECTION CLIFF. AND GET
DESPERATELY NEEDED MONIES OUT
TO STRUGGLING TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS. NOT SINCE IT WASN'T
AND THE INITIAL DESCRIPTION OF
THIS BILL I JUST WANT TO NOTE A
FEW ELEMENTS THIS BILL. THAT
WILL EXTEND TENANT PROTECTIONS
BEYOND THE CURRENT EVICTION
MORATORIUM. AFTER AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT WANTED TO AFFECT
WE HEARD ABOUT SOME LANDLORDS
WHO ARE ADDING SIGNIFICANT LATE
FEES. APPLYING CURRENT TENANT
PAYMENTS RETROACTIVELY TO
BACKGROUND AND OTHER CHARGES.
AS WELL AS CONCERNS RAISED BY
TENANTS ABOUT UNPAID RENTAL
DEBT ASSIGNED TO DEBT
COLLECTORS. AS WELL AS TENANTS
FACING CIVIL LAWSUITS FOR
MISSED RENT. THANKS TO THE
ADVOCACY OF THE STATEWIDE TEN
COMMUNITY RELATED TO AB
FIFTEEN. THIS BILL ADDS
CRITICAL TENANT PROTECTIONS TO
HELP LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD.
AT A TIME WHEN TOO MANY RENTER
HOUSEHOLDS ARE STRUGGLING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET. I WANT JUST
NOTE THAT THIS DISCUSSION IS
NOT OVER WITH THIS BILL. I DO
SHARE THE CONCERN RAISED BY
TENANTS THAT THE FACT THAT
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE THAT A
TENANT RECEIVES. IS DETERMINED
SOLELY BY THE COOPERATION OF A
LANDLORD COULD RESULT IN
OUTCOMES CONTROLLED BY THE
TYPICAL POWER IMBALANCE BETWEEN
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO AGGRESSIVELY
MONITOR THIS PROGRAM IN REAL
TIME. TO ENSURE THE SUCCESS OF
THE PROGRAM AND OUR EFFORTS TO
PREVENT EVICTIONS AND WITH THAT
I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS. TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AROUND
THIS. BOB WOULD LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WE
UNDERSTAND WE ARE GOING TO
RECEIVE MONTHLY MONITORING.
WANTED JUST UNDERSTAND WITH A
LITTLE MORE GRANULARITY HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL PLAN TO
TRACK THE RATE AT WHICH MONEY
GOES OUT. AND WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF LANDLORDS ARE PARTICIPATING
IN THE PROGRAM- CERTAINLY WITH
A LOT OF COMMUNITY NONPROFIT
AND OTHER LOCAL PARTNERS.
ADMINISTERING THIS HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
CONSISTENT REPORTING AND DATA-
ONE ALSO UNDERSTAND. AS THE
MONEY GOES OUT HOW DO WE
EVALUATE IF WE'RE GONNA NEED
MORE- IS THERE MECHANISM TO
DETERMINE FOR EXAMPLE THE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC MAKEUP OF
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS AND
RECEIVING RENTAL. ASSISTANCE
AND THEN. WANT TO UNDERSTAND IF
THERE'S GONNA BE A MECHANISM
FOR DETERMINING HOW MUCH
CONSUMER DEBT TENANTS WERE
RECEIVING. 25% OF THE RENTS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET IT IS. LONGER
TERM WE KNOW THERE'S GOING TO
BE A SUBSET OF TENANTS WILL
STILL BE SADDLED WITH
SIGNIFICANT DEBT. WE'VE GOT A
MONITOR THAT VERY CLOSELY I
JUST WANT UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
CURRENT THINKING OF THE
MINISTRATION ON THIS IS I KNOW
WE'VE HAD. SOME PRELIMINARY
CONVERSATIONS BUT THIS IS
DEFINITELY. AN ISSUE OF CONCERN
I THINK FOR MANY. YES I'M GOING
TO HAND IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
AGENCY. GOOD MORNING I'M MY
NAME IS LYNN BONTA CLEAVER AND
THE DEPUTY SECRETARY OF HOUSING
AT BUSINESS CONSUMER HELPING
AGENCY AND- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION AND WE'LL SEE IF I CAN
GET ALL OF THEM TO PLEASE YOU
PLEASE LET ME KNOW IF I IF I
MISSED ANY OF THE QUESTIONS.
AND SO FIRST IN TERMS OF THE
MONTHLY MONITORING THE PROCESS
FOR THAT IS THAT FOR
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING WITHIN THE STATE
PROGRAM WE WILL HAVE A CONTROL
A CENTRAL DATABASE THAT IS ABLE
TO TRACK THAT INFORMATION- ON A
NEAR REAL TIME BASIS SO
APPLICATIONS ARE. ON STARTING
AND WORKING THEIR WAY THROUGH
THE PROCESS WILL BE COLLECTING
ALL THAT INFORMATION AND BEING
ABLE TO REPORT IN ON ON THAT ON
THAT INFORMATION- I'M FOR
JURISDICTION THAT PARTICIPATE
THROUGH THE BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM
EACH TV WILL BE REQUIRING I'M
WEEKLY REPORT. THAT ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION WHICH
WILL THEN BE CENTRALIZED INTO
THE CENTRAL SYSTEM TO
FACILITATE AN AGGREGATED REPORT
ACROSS THE STATE AND SO IT IS
THE IT'S THE REQUIREMENT OF THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM AND WILL DESIGN
AND REPORTING REQUIREMENTS- TO
HEAR TO THAT TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
TRACK AND THE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHEN APPLICATIONS ARE- STARTED
WHEN THEY STARTED THE PROCESS
AND WHEN THEY ARE COMPLETED AND
THEN WHEN GRANTED MINISTERED AS
WELL. THAT WE CAN PEOPLE THE-
ENTITY THE INTEREST THE OUTRAGE
THAT THE PICK UP RATE AND THEN
THE ULTIMATE THE COUPLE OUTCOME
OF EACH APPLICATION. WE WILL
HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT
LANDLORDS OR TENANTS GETTING AS
ENVISIONED WITHIN THE STATE
PROGRAM- THE APPLICATION PORTAL
CAN BE ACCESSED BY EITHER
LANDLORD OR TENANT AND THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
INFORMATION ABOUT AND- WHEN ONE
PARTY START THE NET AT
APPLICATION AND WHETHER OR NOT
THE SECOND PARTY PARTICIPATE IN
THAT PROCESS. AND WILL ALSO BE
ABLE TO USE THAT INFORMATION TO
BE ABLE TO PUSH NOTIFICATIONS
TO ENCOURAGE PARTICIPATION FROM
ALL PARTIES DROPPED THAT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS MUCH
APPLICATION. HAS BEEN INITIATED.
AND WE DO. BEING ABLE TO CLOCK
AND FOR. ON RACE AND- APPLICANT
ON BOTH TERMS OF LANDMARK AND
TENANTS AND WE WERE CAN. TO
THAT AND- AS AS ERICA- IN
INTERNET COMMENT TO INTO
COMMUNITY. AND OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
WE'RE TARGETING RESOURCES AND
INFORMATION TO. YOU IMPACT THE
COMMUNITIES DEPEND ON IT HAVE
BEEN HIT HARDEST BY HOPE AND
THEN ENTER OF THE AND- OF
CONSUMER DATA AND ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR. IF I'M
UNDERSTANDIG THAT- THAT
INFORMATION CORRECTLY WILL BE
CAPTURING INFORMATION ABOUT AND
THE AMOUNT OF RENTAL ARREARS
THAT HAVE BEEN ACCUMULATED. AND
ARE BEING REQUESTED AS PART OF
THE PROBLEM I'M STILL A FIGHTER
A LANDLORD OR TENANT INITIATE
THE APPLICATION WILL BE ABLE TO
COLLECT THAT INFORMATION AND
THEN RECORD AGAINST THE GROUP
SAID THE ARREARS THAT HAVE BEEN
WEAKENED- THAT HAVE BEEN PAID.
TO THE LANDMARK PARTICIPATE
BIRTH AND THE AMOUNT OF UNPAID
ARREARS YEAH THE LAST. PAYMENT
GO THROUGH THE TENANT PROPER.
AND I BELIEVE I GOT ALL THE
CONFIDENCE OF PLEASE LET ME
KNOW IF THERE. IS AN ELEMENT
THAT I KNOW. I THINK AT A HIGH
LEVEL YOU TO TOUCH ON AND I PER
THAT- YOU KNOW WHAT I WANT TO
SAY AT THIS IS. THIS BILL THESE
BILLS WERE WERE OBVIOUSLY
DIFFICULT TO CRAFT IN PART
BECAUSE WE HAVE TWO MAJOR
UNKNOWNS. WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
THE SIZE THE TOTAL SIZE OF
DEBT. AND WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT
TWO POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
WILL BE ABLE TO COVER IT WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT POTENTIALLY THE BY
DEMONSTRATION WILL PROVIDE
MORE. BUT WE JUST DON'T KNOW.
THE OTHER MAJOR UNKNOWN WITH
REGARD TO THIS BILL THIS TIME
IS. WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
LANDLORDS WILL AGREE TO ACCEPT
THE 80% OF- OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE IN RETURN FOR GIVING
20% OF DEBT. DEPENDING ON THE
ANSWERS TO THOSE QUESTIONS. I
EXPECT IN THE COMING MONTHS
WILL HAVE TO REVISIT THIS
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS GAPS.
AND PROVIDE RELIEF TO
ADDITIONAL TENANTS. WANT TO
JUST TAKE A MOMENT APPRECIATE
LEADERSHIP'S COMMITMENT TO
ENGAGE IN THAT CONVERSATION. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE ARE
NOT LEAVING TENANTS SADDLED
WITH DEBT FOR REASONS THAT ARE
NOT THEY'RE- NOT THEIR FAULT.
AND IT'S MY HOPE THAT. IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S. WORK WILL
BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT
PICTURE LOOKS LIKE AND I DO
HOPE THAT THIS BUDGET
COMMITTEE. CAN FACILITATE THE
REGULAR OVERSIGHT ON THIS AS
FREQUENTLY AS WE NEED TO- TO
FIGURE THIS OUT MOVING INTO THE
FUTURE BECAUSE I DO THANK. UP
BEFORE JUNE THIRTIETH WILL HAVE
TO MAKE SOME REAL DECISIONS
ABOUT WHAT THE FUTURE WILL LOOK
LIKE. WITH THAT CONTACTED HER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH WE'RE
GONNA GO TO MISTER SMITH AND
THEN TO MISTER LEE. AND FOR ANY
MEMBERS WHO AREN'T ON THE DAIS-
WERE MISTER LEE IS THAT'S WHERE
WILL BE SPEAKER. SELF MISTER
SMITH THANK YOU MISTER TURNER
CAME. I'M LOOKING OF THE WHITE
OR WHITE IN THIS CHIU AND WHAT
THE PRICE. TO CHOOSE THE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION. AS THE ENTITY TO.
ADMINISTER THIS NEW PROGRAM.
AND WHAT CONFIDENCE. DO WE HAVE
IN THE STATE. THAT CDFI HAS A
CAPACITY THE EFFICIENCY. TO RUN
THIS PROGRAM AND DISTRIBUTE THE
MONEY QUICKLY BECAUSE THAT IS A
PROCESS WE NEED TO GET THE
MONEY OUT. TO THE LANDLORDS AND
TO THE RENTERS THAT NEED
ASSISTANCE AS QUICK AS POSSIBLE.
YES MISTER SMITH- I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT IT IS NOT A CDFI AT
THIS POINT WE HAVE- AGENCY ARE
DOING RESEARCH ON WHO COULD BE
AT. A SOLID THIRD PARTY
IMPLEMENTOR- AND THEY WANT TO
EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID AND TO
ADDRESS THIS PROGRAM QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE I'M GONNA HAVE THIS
QUESTION OVER TO AGENCY FOR THE
PARTICULAR REGARDS TO THE
ACTIONS THAT THEY TAKE THUS
FAR- AND I'VE SPOKEN ABOUT SOME
OF THE IMPORTANT EXPECTATIONS
THEY HAVE ON THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR- WITH MY FOLLOW.
A FELLOW COLLEAGUES TO MAKE
SURE THE MONEY WAS DISTRIBUTED
WHO IS GOING TO BE WATCHING OR
THE OVERSIGHT TO MAKE SURE THE
MONEY IS DISTRIBUTED CORRECTLY.
AND WE HAVE NO OTHER ISSUES IN
THE ONE DEPARTMENT TO THE OTHER.
I'M SURE IF I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE U. S. TREASURY HAS SPENT
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS DIRECTLY STATE AT THIS
POINT AND THAT THOSE. THOSE
DOLLARS WILL BE- IT USED
CONTRACT WITH A THIRD PARTY
IMPLEMENTOR AND H. T. T. STATE
AGENCY WILL BE HOLDING BACK LAW
HOLD BACK. BUT I TELL. WE
APPROVAL TO DO SO NOTHING HAS.
MOVED FORWARD THIS ALL GREASED
AT THIS POINT I'M LINKING OUR
TO YOU FOR SOME MORE DETAILS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AB AND TO
THE OF THE- PARTY EMPLOYEE. I'M
WITH WITH THE STATE FEEDBACK
FROM THREE OH EIGHT EIGHT.
WHICH IDENTIFY- INFORMATION
ABOUT HER A- AND- SHALL. AND
ALSO- IMPLANTED MATH THAT
DENTURE THAT I AT AT. ADVOCATE
UNITY EVERY WHO APPLY TO THE
STAKEHOLDER. ON PROVIDE
CONVEYED TO US. AND THEN WE
HAVE SUDDENLY GONE THROUGH
SERIES OF LISTENING- WITH. TO
BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WRAPPED THE
LAST YEAR. I'M STILL USING ALL
THAT INFORMATION WE THEN BEGAN
IF YOU DESIGN WHAT WE THOUGHT
WOULD BE THAT THAT THE SYSTEM
REQUIREMENTS- TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT TECHNICAL
CAPABILITIES THAT THEY NEEDED
TO BE RESPONSIVE TO. WHAT THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE WERE HEARING
FROM STAKEHOLDERS AND
JURISDICTION BUT ALSO TO THINK
THROUGH THE PROCESSING AND- HOW
TO MEET THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS ACTUALLY. IT
BECAME I'M AWARE OF THE- THAT
THAT PROGRAM GRANDMOTHER IF I'M
ISSUED BY THE US TREASURY. AND
SO FROM THERE WE DID A NUMBER
OF WORKSHOPS WITH DIFFERENT-
PROGRAM AND IMPLEMENTERS TO BE
ABLE TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
CAPABILITIES AND BE ABLE TO
DEFINE. WHAT WOULD BE THE RIGHT
PARAMETERS SYSTEM REQUIREMENTS
AND- SERVICES THAT WOULD BE
NECESSARY TO BE SUCCESSFUL WITH.
WITH THE WITH THIS PROGRAM
POLLUTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK ONE OTHER THAN A MYSTERY.
I FEEL IT IS WORKING I FEEL
LIKE I'M HERE TO GIVE MY PUBLIC
COMMENT RIGHT NOW BUT I ASSURE
YOU I AM A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE- SO FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO THANK MADABA JORDY
LEADER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND LEADERSHIP FOR THE
COMMITMENT TO KEEPING WORKING
FAMILIES HOUSE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. IS AN IMMENSE ANXIETY
AMONGST THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE
LOSE THEIR HOMES. YOU KNOW I'M
REMINDED LAST NIGHT DURING THE
AMAZING. VIOLENT WINDSTORM THIS
HAPPENING DURING LAST NIGHT IN
SACRAMENTO THAT PEOPLE ARE
ANXIOUS. THEY WANT TO KNOW IF
THEY HAVE THE SECURITY OF A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS. AND THEY
WANT TO HAVE S MUCH TIME TO
KNOW THAT'S POSSIBLE WE ARE.
FOUR DAYS BEFORE THE EVICTION
MORE TERMS ARE TO EXPIRE AD I
CANNOT TELL YOU THE AMOUNT. OF
CALLS AND MESSAGES WE GET IN
OUR OFFICE AND DIRECTLY TO ME
ASKING. IS THIS GOING TO PASS
WHAT ARE THE DETAILS ON HOW WE
CAN ACCESS THESE FUNDS. I DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT OF
OUR LEADERSHIP. TO WORKING AT A
SPEEDY DEAL AND GETTING OUT THE
REALLY FUNDS AND AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. AND MAKING SURE THE
EVICTION MORE TERMS EXTENDED
EXTENDED TILL JUNE. ALTHOUGH
I'M CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
THE PROGRESS OF THE PANDEMIC SO
I DO THINK PROBABLY WILL BE
REVISITING THIS CONVERSATION
SOON. AND IN RIVAS IN CONCERT
THE CONVERSATION. I REALLY HOPE
THAT. WILL BE INCLUDING A TEN
ADVOCACY GROUPS IN THIS BECAUSE
THE TENANT ADVOCACY GROUPS.
HAVE A LOT OF FRUSTRATION
ANXIETY THAT I. RIGHTFULLY
UNDERSTANDS I THINK I'M ONE OF
THE FEW MEMBERS OF OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE THAT IS NOT A
PROPERTY OWNER. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT ANXIETY THAT
YOU COULD BE. ONE MISSED
PAYMENT AWAY. FOR HAVING SLEEP
IN YOUR CAR. HAVE ANY COUCH
SURF. AND IN WINTER NIGHTS LIKE
THESE I'M REMINDED THAT A CAR
EVEN LOOKING TO BE DRY. FEELS
LIKE BEING IN A DRY
REFRIGERATOR. IT IS VERY DEEPLY
UNPLEASANT. WE DON'T WANT THAT
TO BE HAPPENING TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS. IN ONE SURVEY
THERE ARE MORE THAN A MILLION
CALIFORNIA TENANTS. THERE
BEHIND A RED AT THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY. THAT'S ONE IN
FIVE RENTERS IN THE STATE ONE
IN FIVE. AND THAT'S INCLUDES
300-003-7000 HOUSEHOLDS IN MY
HOME COUNTY SANTA CLARA ALONE.
SO THE NEED IS REAL AND HIS
IDEAS VERY MUCH REAL. AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT TO
KEEPING OUR FAMILIES HOUSE BUT
I AM ALSO WORRIED THAT IN THIS
NEGOTIATION IN THIS PROPOSAL IT
DOES GIVE TOO MUCH POWER. TO
LANDLORDS WHO TRADITIONALLY
HAVE A POWER IMBALANCE OVER THE
TESTS SO I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ABOUT THE PROPOSAL BUT
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND I APPRECIATE
THE LEADERSHIP COMMITMENT. TO
KEEP WORKING ON THIS ISSUE AND
KEEP THE DATA TRACKING TO MAKE
SURE THE PROGRAM IS SUCCESSFUL
CALIFORNIANS. SO MY FIRST
QUESTION IS. LOOKING OVER THE
BILL IF A LANDLORD OPTS INTO
THE PROGRAM OR THE REQUIRED TO
APPLY FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL
TENANT THAT IS ELIGIBLE THAT
OWES BACK RENT. AT ONE TIME. OR
ARE THEY ALLOW DISCRETION TO
PICK WHICH TENANT IS ALL OF THE
PROGRAM. THAT'S MY FIRST
QUESTION OTHER THAN ONE ATTACK.
YES CAN I TURN THAT QUESTION
OVER TO- ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
THAT AGENCY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEE AS ACTIVE AS A DIVISION THE
LANDLORD COULD YOU EITHER THEY
COULD EITHER APPLY IN A BATCH
FOR ALL THE TIME OR THEY CAN DO
SO ON A ROLLING BASIS. OKAY
THANK YOU. MY SECOND QUESTION
IS. UNDER THE PROPOSAL IF A
LANDLORD OPT INTO THE PROGRAM.
THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY. GIVEN 80%
OF THE DEBT OUT. IF I IF I
TENANTS APPLIES WHEN A LANDLORD
DECLINES THEY ARE GIVEN THE 25%
DEBT 25% DEBT OWED REQUIRED TO
STATE HOUSE. THAT FEELS TO ME
LIKE A DIRECT UNICAL INEQUITY
AN IMBALANCE SO WHERE WOULD THE
NUMBER BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE AND
EIGHTY PUMP FROM. CAN I GET
THIS ONE TO AMY AND AGENCY. HI
AMY WE JUST NEED TO START
TALKING. YOU'RE A MICROPHONE IS
OFF. ALL IS IT LOOKS LIKE A
MEANS- MICROPHONE IS OFF
MEMBERS I'D WE CAN GET BACK TO
YOU SOON- THANK YOU I JUST WANT
TO SAY- THAT- OKAY LET'S GO.
I'M SURE WINNER WHEN WE THOUGHT
WHEN THE POLICE AFTER THE
STRUCTURE THERE WERE A COUPLE
THINGS THAT WERE BOUNDING THE
CONVERSATION TO BEGIN WITH IN
THE FIRST IS THAT THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM- AT REQUIRED FOR THAT
THE OFFER GO TO EVEN GO TO THE
LANDLORD AND THAT WE WORK WITH
A LANDMARK- AND ONLY SHOULD THE
LANDLORD NOT BE PARTICIPATING
THEN DO WE THEN GO THROUGH TO
THAT HAND ON THE BACK PART OF
THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. AND
THEN WHEN WE WERE LOOKINGAT
THE- THE BALANCE BETWEEN THE
80% OF THE 20% THANK FIRST
THERE WAS THAT THEY WERE THE
PROGRAM TO INCENTIVIZE THE
LANDLORD TO PARTICIPATE BECAUSE
BACK INTO THE ABILITY TO THAN
TO BE ABLE TO- ARRAY THE
REMAINING RENTAL ARREARS AND IF
THERE'S A THOUGHT AROUND THE
80% TWENTY TWENTY FIVE- IS THAT
IF YOU GET TO THE TENANT
PARTICIPATION THEN THAT'S FINE
THEN THAT THAT 25% IS ENOUGH TO
ENSURE THAT THE TIME AND WILL
CONTINUE TO A HOUSE UNDER THE
EXTENSION OF THE REGULATORY
PROCESS- BUT THE GOAL WOULD BE
TO BE ABLE TO REMOVE AS MUCH-
RENTAL THAT AS POSSIBLE WHICH
IS ACHIEVED. ONLY THROUGH THE
DIRECT LANDMARK PAYMENT. OKAY
THANK YOU. I DEFINITELY. THAT
AND I UNDER. AND WANT TO
INCENTIVE LAND FOR JUST SO I DO
HAVE. THAT FOUGHT. IT DOES ODD
TO ME THAT WHEN A LANDLORD
APPRECIATE A PROACTIVE TENANT
APPLYING FOR THEMSELVES. SO IT
SEEMS QUITE PUNITIVE TO A
TENANT WHO WOULD TAKE EFFORTS
INTO THEIR OWN HANDS TO. APPLY
FOR IT. SO I REALLY HOPE IN THE
FUTURE IF WE HAVE MORE. FUNDS
COVER THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS
WE ARE HOPEFUL FOR. THAT THIS
SPLIT IN DEBT. DEBT PAYOFF
ESSENTIALLY IS MUCH MUCH MORE
EQUITABLE. SINCE OBVIOUSLY THE
MONEY GOES ALANLAR DIRECTLY
ANYWAYS IT DOESN'T POCKET INTO
THE TENANT. ALL RIGHT WELL MY
THIRD QUESTION IS THIS I'M- I
APPRECIATE OVIOUSLY THE SPEED
WITH ONE AND GETS THE MONEY OUT
BY MARCH BUT I AM WORRIED THERE
MIGHT BE A REPEAT AND OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS WHY THE DATA METRICS
ARE IMPORTANT I AM WORRIED
THERE COULD BE A REPEAT OF THE
PPP LOAN FIASCO FROM TWENTY
TWENTY- WE'RE BIG BUSINESSES
AND CORPORATIONS. EIGHT UP THE
LINE SHARES OF THESE FUNDS
BEFORE SMALL BUSINESSES COULD
APPLY. I HAVE THE SAME CONCERN
THAT SMALL LANDLORDS MAY NOT
GET THE CHANCE APPLY. THE OUTER
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN- SO HOW
WILL WE ENSURE THAT SMALL
LANDLORDS WHO MAY ONLY BE
RENTING OUT THEIR SECOND HOMES
OR TRIPLEX WITH A FEW TENANTS
THAT THEY HAVE KEPT ON IN GOOD
FAITH MAY NOT. WHO MAY NOT
POSSESS THE RESOURCES THAT
CORPORATE LANDLORDS HAVE HAVE
PRIORITY IF NOT TACKLE ACCESS
TO THESE REALLY FUNDS IN MARCH.
YESTERDAY I'M JUST TO POINT OUT
THAT- PART OF THE EXPECTATION
OF THE THIRD PARTY IMPLEMENTOR
IS THAT THEY PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. AS WELL AS RUN A-
ROBUST COMMUNICATION OUTREACH
PROGRAM TO- IT TO ALL THE
PARTICIPANTS ACROSS THE STATE
AND SO THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
US I THINK YOUR POINT. IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS CONSIDERED
IN THE PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
BECAUSE OF EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED WITH PPP THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE MOST NEEDY- HOUSEHOLDS
WOULD RECEIVE THIS SUPPORT AND
SO THE- THE WAY THAT IN WHICH
THE MONEY IT'S GOING TO BE
ALLOCATED IS IN ROUNDS AND THAT
FIRST ROUND. IS REALLY TO
ADDRESS THE DEEPEST NEED IS FOR
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE BELOW 50%
AREA MEDIAN INCOME. OR WHO HAVE
BEEN UNEMPLOYED FOR NINETY DAYS
AND SO WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE DEEPEST NEED THERE
IN THAT FIRST ROUND- SO THAT'S
THE SORT OF THE PRIORITY GROUP
AS YOU MENTION- BUT ALSO
UNDERSTANDING THE NEEDS TO GET
THAT INFORMATION OUT TO OUR
REGION MAKE SURE THAT IT'S THE
SMALL LANDLORDS NOT THE BIG IS.
THAT ARE ARE YOU KNOW THE DATE
THAT THEY HAVE. THE SAME
BENEFIT UP FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SO THAT'S A NEED
BASED ON THE TENTH CORRECT. IT
IS BASED ON THE TENTS YES SO I
DO APPRECIATE THE KNOWLEDGE AT
THE DEEPEST NEED IS BASED ON
THE TENANT YEAH OBVIOUSLY THIS
PROPOSAL DOES REFLECT THAT
INEQUITY WHERE THE TENANT IF
THEY APPLY WITH THE DEEPEST
NEED GETS 25% OF THE DEBT PAID
OFF NOW INSTEAD OF THE EIGHTY
PERCENT. SO I HOPE IN THE
FUTURE THAT WILL BE LOOKED AT
MORE CLOSELY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THOSE ARE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
DOCTOR ARAMBULA THAN TO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- THE FIRST
TIME. SOMETIMES WHEN WE GET
THESE PROPOSALS LATER IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR US AND I
APOLOGIZE IF MY QUESTION IS OFF
BUT I WANT TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING IF SOME OF THESE
FUNDS CAN BE USED FOR OUR HUMAN
SERVICES DEPARTMENT. I'M
SPECIFICALLY TALKING ABOUT THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION LETTER WHERE THEY
SPOKE ABOUT MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES CAL WORKS CHILD
WELFARE AND FOSTER CARE. YES
ARAMBULA SAID THESE FINES ARE
SPECIFICALLY FOR RENTAL AND-
LEASE AND NOT NOT AND- AND
UTILITIES ARE INCLUDED IN THAT
AS WELL SO NOT FOR SERVICES- HE-
OF THESE FUNDS MAY BE USED FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
PROGRAM ITSELF AS WELL- BUT
AGAIN ALL TOWARDS RENTAL
ASSISTANCE. UTILITY PERFECT IN
THAT THEN IS THE EXACT REASON
WHY THEY ARE EXCLUDED I THINK I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ELEVATE THE FACT THAT MANY OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THESE
PROGRAMS. ARE LIMITED BY THE
PROGRAMS THEMSELVES- THE
PARTICIPANTS OFTENTIMES HAVE TO
EITHER BE HOMELESS OR NEARLY
ADDICTED BEFORE THEY'RE ABLE TO
RECEIVE. ASSISTANCE AND SO I'M
DEFINITELY TALKING ABOUT THE
HOUSING AND DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM BE HOME SAFE PROGRAM
WITHIN APS THE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME AND THE HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM. C. W. D. AS
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT HAVING
SOME FLEXIBILITY AS AN
INCREASED FUNDS WILL ALLOW US
TO BETTER PREVENT THOSE WHO ARE
ON SOCIAL SERVICES. FROM BEING
AFFECTED AND BECOMING HOMELESS
THERE'S A REAL ADVANTAGE FOR US
TO BEING PROACTIVE AND TO HELP
TO PREVENT THOSE WHO ARE
ALREADY ON OUR SOCIAL SAFETY
NETS TO. BEING EXACERBATED AND
WORSENED AND JUST WANTED TO
ELEVATE THAT CONVERSATION HERE
TODAY AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TO
THIS ADDICTION MORATORIUM TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
COME BACK AND HELP TO FILL SOME
OF THOSE GAPS THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST IN THOSE PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU'RE
JUST GONNA DO A QUICK QUICK
FOLLOW UP ON DR EMPHASIS ABOUT
POINT AS WELL- THE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION IS- THE MONEY CAN
BE USED TO PAY UTILITIES AS
WELL. BUT THE IF THE MONEY'S
GOING TO THE LANDLORDS HOW
WOULD DID TEN AND GET THE MONEY
TO PAY FOR THE TWO OF THESE.
YES THE PRIORITY IS FOR THE
RENTAL ARREARS- MISTER CHANG
AND IF. UTILITIES ARE INCLUDED
IN THE COST OF THEIR FRIENDS
THAT THEY WOULD BE COVERED- BUT
AGAIN IT'S- THAT THE FOCUS OF
THIS PROGRAM IS FOR RENTAL
ARREARS. I WILL ASK MY
COLLEAGUES IF THEY HAVE ANY
OTHER DETAILS IN REGARDS TO
YOUR QUESTION. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS AMY WILSON I HOPE THAT
MIKE- TECHNICAL ISSUE HAS BEEN
RESOLVED AND YOU CAN HEAR ME-
I'VE JUST WOULD CLARIFY THAT
THE FEDERAL LAW. AS IT
PRESCRIBES PAYMENTS TO.
LANDLORDS SIMILARLY IT WOULD
PRESCRIBE THE PAYMENT TO THE
UTILITY PROVIDER- BUT AS ERICA-
THAT MENTIONED THE ARE THE
FOCUS OF THIS PROGRAM REALLY IS
THE STABILIZING HOUSEHOLDS-
THROUGH THE PRIORITIZATION OF-
RENTAL ARREARS- AND THROUGH
PAYMENTS LANDLORDS. OKAY THANK
YOU WHAT WE'RE GONNA GO NOT TO
MISS RIVAS. WHAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK OUR LEADERSHIP OF
BOTH HOUSES THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE AMAZING BUDGET STAFF-
FOR WORKING TO PREPARE THIS
HEARING TODAY AND WORKING ON
THIS PROGRAM- AS WE ARE
DISCUSSING THIS BILL TODAY
SOMEONE IS LOSING THEIR HOME.
TO MANY FAMILIES ARE ON THE
VERGE OF BEING UNABLE TO PAY
THEIR RENT EVEN PRIOR TO COVE
IT AND NOW THE THIS PANDEMIC
HAS EXACERBATED THAT. WE KNOW
THAT THE RICH HAVE GOTTEN
RICHER DURINGTHE PANDEMIC AND
THE POOR HAVE GOTTEN POORER
DURING THIS PANDEMIC- WE HAVE
COME TO APPRECIATE THOSE WHO
WORK IN THE CENTRAL JOBS HAVE
CONTINUED TO WORK TO SHIP OUR
ORDERS TO PREPARE FOOD STOPPER
GROCERY SHELVES WE'RE FACING A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS WE KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA'S FACING WITH
THE WORST HOMELESSNESS
DISASTERS IN THE NATION. THAT'S
WHY IT'S SO CRITICAL OF THAT
THE STATE PROVIDE OF THIS
PROGRAM SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES- WE NEED
TO ACT AGGRESSIVELY AND I
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT HAS
BEEN DONE- AND I KNOW THAT
WE'RE WORKING HARD TO ESTABLISH
THIS PROGRAM AND GET IN GETTING
IT UP AS SOON AS POSSIBLE- SO
MY QUESTIONS ARE RELATED. TO
THE ACCESSIBILITY OF THE
APPLICATION AND THE TECHNOLOGY
SIDE OF WHILE EURO WE SOMETIMES
WE GO TOO FAST AND WE DON'T
EVALUATE- HOW ACCESSIBLE THE
APPLICATION IS- FOR THOSE THAT
ARE LESS TECHNOLOGY LITERATE
AND ARE REALLY IN NEED- WILL
THERE BE. SUPPORT OF FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT AS TECH LITERATE
AS OTHERS- TO APPLY FOR THIS
APPLICATION LIKE WITH
APPLICATION BE OFFERED IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES- AND ALSO.
WHAT ARE WE DOING OR WHAT WHAT
WAIT ARE WE APPLYING- IN
SELECTING THE THIRD PARTY- THAT
WILL ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM.
IN THEIR TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGICAL CAPABILITY AND
THEIR EXPERIENCE- IN IN
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM VIA
THE INTERNET LIKE THIS ONE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
MISTER BASS AND- YES ABSOLUTELY
THAT THE PROGRAM IMPLEMENTOR
EXPECTATIONS INCLUDE THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO STAND UP
AN ONLINE PLATFORM WHICH WILL
BE ACCESSIBLE- FOR THOSE-
ACROSS THE STATE WHO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE I'M BUT TO YOUR
POINT IN REGARDS TO THOSE
FAMILIES- THOSE LANDLORDS WHO
ARE NOT AS TECHNICALLY SAVVY-
THAT WHAT THE EXPECTATION IS
ALSO THAT THREE THIS CONTRACT-
THE IMPLEMENTER WOULD BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. AND AGAIN THIS IS
INFORMED BY A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATION HAPPEN AROUND
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT
STAKEHOLDER WORK FOR- THAT THAT
ENVISIONED- HOW HOW UP THIRD
PARTY WOULD ASSIST- ACROSS THE
STATE. AND VARIOUS POPULATIONS
SOME OF WHICH AS YOU SAID MAY
NOT BE- AS SAUDI ONLINE I'M I'M
NOT GOING TO ASK MY- AGENCY.
PARTNERS IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO
ADD ANYTHING. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY RIVAS AND THE IS ONE
OF THE CORE REQUIREMENTS THAT
WE ENVISION BUILDING AND THAT
THE CONTRACT. AND WINTERS SAID
MENTIONING THE POINT AROUND
THAT TECHNOLOGY AND WHAT WHAT
WE ARE LEARNING VERY QUICKLY IS
THAT WHILE THERE ARE ON
LIMITATIONS OFTEN IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO YOU AND ACCESS
THE COMPUTER. AND MOBILE IS
OFTEN HERE MUCH MORE AVAILABLE
AND SO WE ARE REQUIRING THAT
EVERYTHING BE A MOBILE BASED AS
WELL AS AND ACTIVISTS. BY AND
REGULAR COMPUTER AND WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRING AND THAT THERE WOULD
BE AT THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT INCLUDED- MULTILINGUAL
CALL CENTER- MULTILINGUAL AND.
EMAIL AND TAX. SERVICES TO BE
ABLE TO ACROSS. AND THEN ALSO
IN WOULD BE THE M. THAT IN
PERSON- BUT COPE AT THE AT.
SUPPORT SERVICES- SO YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT THEY WOULD BE- AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAD ORIGINAL
JURISDICTION ON THAT THEY WERE
RESPONSIBLE CHIU BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE AND DIRECT SUPPORT Q.
AND AN APPLICANT WHO NEEDED AN
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE AND BEING
ABLE TO SUBMIT AN APPLICATION.
AND IN TERMS OF THE BILL WAIT-
THAT WE WOULD. PUT ON DEATH
THIS CAPABILITY AND I THINK
IT'S A VERY PROMINENT FEATURE
IN THE DESIGN- AS IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM HAVE A LOT OF
COMPLEXITIES IN TERMS OF
RECORDING. AND BEING ABLE TO
MANAGE A PRETTY COMPLEX AND
DUPLICATION OF BENEFITS
REQUIREMENTS AND SO WE DO
BELIEVE THAT HAVING I'M VERY
VERY AND THE PAST DECADE
TECHNOLOGY ON THE BACK AND TO
BE ABLE TO. DO THAT YOU NEED TO
DO THE DEED IS LOCATION MARK-
BE ABLE TO MATCH THE
APPLICATION BE ABLE TO AND
PROTECTING DANTE AND BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT. THAT THEIR- THAT
FRAUD APPAREILS THE FRAUD IS
MINIMIZED THE GREATEST DEGREE
POSSIBLE AND THOSE ARE ALL VERY
VERY IMPORTANT CRITERIA AND THE
FACT THAT CATIONS THAT WE WOULD
ENVISION- THE OTHER THING TO DO
I THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT IS
THAT WE THOUGHT A LOT ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT. NOT ONLY ARE
IS THAT THE SERVICE PROVIDER
THAT HAS THE TECHNICAL
EXPERIENCE THAT THAT THAT THEY
HAVE THE TECHNICAL EXPERIENCES
WORKING IN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY KOBE. AND
SO HOW THAT COMMUNITY BASED
FOCUS THAT WILL ENABLE THEM TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDED THAT THE
TECHNICAL POLLUTION THAT THAT
ME INDIVIDUAL WHERE THEY'RE AT.
I'M SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THE
GREATEST THE CLASS AND
COMPLETING APPLICATIONS. AND-
DISTRIBUTING FONG. IF OKAY IF I
MAY I WANTED TO JUST AT A
COUPLE OF A POINTS RELAY TO-
AND- I WANTED TO NOTE THAT- IN
ADDITION- MATERIALS AND
INFORMATION WILL BE AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE STATE'S OUSING IS
KEY WEBSITE- WHICH IS- AT IT
OUR FIRST ON IT BOTH SENATE IT
IS OFFERED IN BOTH ENGLISH AND
SPANISH BUT THEN- MOVING BEYOND
THAT TO THE- REQUIRED TENANT
NOTIFICATIONS THAT ARE IN THE
BILL- IN THE CIVIL CODE
SECTIONS ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE
POINT OH THREE AND- FOR- THOSE
ARE REQUIRED TO BE TRANSLATED.
IN THE LANGUAGE BEFORE PROVIDED
IN THE LANGUAGE THAT THE- THAT
THE LEASE WAS DEVELOPED IN AND
THE- STATE DOES- PROVIDE THOSE
NOTIFICATIONS TRANSLATED IN THE
FIVE MOST PREVALENT LANGUAGE IS
SPOKEN- IN THE STATE- ADAM AT
AS A STARTING POINT AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO THAT- RELATIVE TO-
IMMIGRATION STATUS- THE
PROGRAM- IS SILENT ON THAT
MATTER AND- WE HAVE- ALSO
INCLUDED AT THE OR ARE AMONG
OUR INSTRUCTIONS FOR THIS THIRD
PARTY IMPLEMENTOR. ARE ON THAT
THEY THINK CREATIVELY WHEN IT
COMES TO IDENTITY VERIFICATION-
RECOGNIZING THAT NOT EVERYONE
HAS ALL THE SAME TRADITIONAL.
DOCUMENTATION AND SIMILARLY IN
THOSE REQUIRED NOTIFICATIONS I
SHOULD HAVE MENTIONED THAT IN
THE CIVIL CODE THERE IS A
POINT- ABOUT FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE- AT BEING AVAILABLE
AND- THAT- THE PROGRAM MAY BE
AVAILABLE YOU MAY BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE PROGRAM REGARDLESS OF
YOUR- CITIZENSHIP OR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THANK YOU
WHERE TO GO TO NEXT TO GO TO
THE DOCTOR WOULDN'T IN A SMALL
NUMBER MATHIS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT'S GONE INTO THIS
I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS- SO.
IF YOU'RE A LARGE COUNTY FOR
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE YOU'LL GET IT YOU CAN
GET A DIRECT BLOCK GRANTS FROM
IT IS THAT H. CD OR WHERE IS
THAT BLOCK GRANT COMING FROM. I
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE ABOVE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND SORRY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND POPULATION
WILL RECEIVE A DIRECT- GRANT
FROM THE US TREASURY. IN
ADDITION TO ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S RECEIVING DIRECTLY
FROM THE US TREASURY. WILL BE
ALLOCATED OUT TO ENTITIES BASED
ON- POPULATION OR POPULATION
BASIS. AND SO THOSE ENTITIES-
YOU YOU HAVE SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
ENTITIES OF. POPULATIONS ABOUT
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND YES
THEY WOULD ALSO BE. ELIGIBLE
FOR A BLOCK GRANT THROUGH THE
STATE PROGRAM AND THEY CAN
DECIDE IF THEY WANT TO.
PARTICIPATE IN THAT BLOCK GRANT
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO FOLLOW
THE PROVISIONS OF THAT STATE
RENTAL PROGRAM BUT SO THAT THEY
COULD RECEIVE TO BLOCK GRANTS
ONE IS A DIRECT ONE FROM THE U.
S. TREASURY AND A SECOND ONE
WOULD BE. THROUGH- EACH CD. SO
START OF COUNTIES THAT ARE
GREATER THAN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ARE YOU SAYING COULD
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL BLOCK GRANTS
ADDITIONAL. FOR ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT OTHER COUNTIES
MIGHT BE ABLE TO RECEIVE. SO
WHAT I'M SAYING IS THAT THEY
WOULD RECEIVE A DIRECT GRANT
ALREADY FROM THE FENCE AND THAT
THEY WOULD ALSO BE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE GRANTS- GRANT DOLLARS
FROM THE STATE PROGRAM- I PER
PERSON- PER POPULATION BASED.
YEAH AND THAT'S NOT JUST FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT'S EVERY
EVERY. JURISDICTION IN ACCOUNT-
IN THE IN THE STATE COULD
RECEIVE AN ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF
DOLLARS. SO COULD A
PROPORTIONALLY RECEIVE LARGER
COUNTIES PROPORTIONALLY RECEIVE
MORE MONEY THAN PER CAPITA THAN
SMALLER COUNTIES. SO I MENTION
THAT THERE IS ACTUALLY A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION CARVE OUT
FOR SMALL COUNTY. AND THAT IS A
FLOW THAT CREATES A FLOOR THAT
IS ACTUALLY TWO TIMES HIGHER
THAN THEY WHAT THEY WOULD
NORMALLY HAVE RECEIVED IF YOU
ARE LOOKING JUST OUT OF HER
POPULATION BASIS UNDERSTANDING
NEEDS AND SMALL COUNTRIES AND
CITIES. WITHIN THOSE COUNTIES-
WAS THE PURPOSE AND THE
RATIONALE BEHIND HAVING A
LARGER CAR ABOUT THAT.
APPRECIATE THAT BUT YOU DID
REGISTER MY QUESTION- IT COULD.
BE HARDER TO. POTENTIALLY
RECEIVE MORE PER CAPITA. THAN
RESIDENTS OF SMALLER COUNTIES
THAT WAS MY QUESTION I UNDER I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAID.
BUT WE SAW THROUGH THE CURES
ACT THAT SMALLER COUNTIES GOT
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIT- WHEN IT
CAME TO COBIT RELIEF SO I'M
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT. WE GET
FAIR TREATMENT I REPRESENT FIVE
COUNTIES THEY'RE ALL LESS THAN
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IN THE WAY I'VE SEEN THIS IS
THAT IF YOU'RE A BIG COUNTY YOU
CAN GET MONEY DIRECTLY FROM THE
FEDERAL TREASURY AND YOU GET
DIRECT MONIES DIRECTLY
SOMEWHERE ELSE. BUT I'M A
SMALLER COUNTY. I HAVE TO GO
THROUGH ANOTHER PROCESS. THIS
FEELS LIKE THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT WHICH
HAS BEEN A NIGHTMARE FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE MY DISTRICT BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THESE KINDS OF THINGS SO THIS
I'M JUST TRYING TO SEE YOU KNOW
IS IT GOING TO BE FAIR PER
CAPITA. NUMBER ONE. CROSS THE
BOARD. BECAUSE THERE'S THAT
THERE IS A MISCONCEPTION THAT
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN SMALLER
COUNTIES. HAVE LOWER COST OF
LIVING AND THAT'S A FALLACY
BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU IT'S NOT
TRUE- AND- I JUST WANT TO
ASSURE. THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA
END UP IN A SIMILAR SITUATION
WHERE. WE'RE SHORT CHANGED
BECAUSE WE OFTEN ARE. THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN THE
THINGS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
ABILITY TO TAP INTO THIS TO
MOBILE DEVICES AND INTERNET AND
ALL THAT. DOESN'T WORK IN A LOT
OF THE DISPLAY AREA THAT I
REPRESENT. YOU CAN DRIVE ON THE
HIGHWAY HIGHWAY ONE OF ONE FROM
MY HOME TO THE NORTHERN PART OF
MY DISTRICT IN 50% OF THAT
HIGHWAY THERE'S NO CELL
COVERAGE. THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE INTERNET
ACCESS WE DON'T HAVE MOBILE.
AND THEY ARE BEHIND ON THEIR
RENT OUT THERE HOW WE CAN REACH
THEM. YES I'M GONNA TURN THE
QUESTION IN REGARDS TO- PER
PERSON- ALLOCATION TO
COLLEAGUES BUT I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT. AGAIN THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WILL BE PROVIDED
BOTH BY EACH CD TO. AND THAT
THIRD PARTY IMPLEMENTOR IS BOTH
A TECHNOLOGICAL AND ALSO-
WHAT'S ON THE GROUND SO WALKING
THROUGH COMMUNICATING WITH-
LANDLORD AND TENANT. ADVOCACY
GROUPS AND OTHERS ON THE GROUND
AND IT'S AN ALL NECESSARILY.
TECHNOLOGICAL SUCH YOUR POINT
NOT AT NOT ALL POPULATIONS ARE
EITHER SAUDI ARE COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT WITH THOSE SETTINGS
SO ONE I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT AS ONE MEANS OF
COMMUNICATING THAT INFORMATION
TO. BIG AND SMALL COUNTIES- AND
LYNN OR- ANYTHING- ANY OTHER
DETAILS ON THAT BEFORE YOU DO
THAT. I JUST LIKE TO SAY FREE
TO HISTORICALLY THAT EXTRA
LAYER OF BUREAUCRACY HAS BEEN
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR SMALLER
COUNTIES HISTORICALLY. AT HOUSE
AND SO. A TO A THIRD. THAT WE
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT THIS POINT
MAY HAVE GOOD TIES TO KEEP.
THESE MAY NOT- I DON'T HAVE A
REAL COMFORTABLE FEELING WITH
ABOUT SOME OF THIS RIGHT NOW
AND- YOU KNOW I WANT I'M GONNA
SUPPORT WHAT WE DO HERE. BUT
I'M TELLING YOU NOW THAT BASED
ON MY PAST EXPERIENCE WITH
THINGS LIKE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANTS IN
SMALLER COMMUNITIES. I DON'T
HAVE A WARM AND FUZZY FEELING
ABOUT THIS SO I'M HOPING THAT
I'M WRONG- AND- BUT IF I'M NOT.
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR ABOUT IT.
I CAN I CAN- I CAN HELP TO
ANSWER AND UNDERSTOOD WERE LATE
TO THE DEAN OF THE POPULATION
DISTRIBUTION I THINK ONE THING
THAT'S PRETTY IMPORTANT TO KNOW
IS THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THOSE
THE POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA
THAT IS AND- WILL RECEIVE A
DIRECT FEDERAL ALLOCATION AND
THAT COMPRISES ABOUT 95% OF THE
POPULATION. AND SO IF THAT THE
UNDER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND I'M
COMMUNITIES ARE THOSE THAT THE
MAKE UP 5% OF THE POPULATION
AND SO IN LOOKING AT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE STATE
PORTION AND WE SENSUALLY
DOUBLED UP SO THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE THE SAME THEY WOULD HAVE
THE SAME PER CAPITA- FORMULA AS
THE JURISDICTIONS THAT WERE
REPEATING THE DIRECT
APPLICATION AS WELL. AND DO WE
REALLY DO THINK THAT WE WORKED
TO CREATE A GEOGRAPHICAL
POPULATION EQUITY WITHIN-
WITHIN THAT STRUCTURE AND THE
OTHER THING THAT AND WE NEEDED
INCLUDE AND THE LANGUAGE IS
THAT ORDERED DICTION THAT ARE
RECEIVING IT AT THAT THAT OFTEN
FOR A STATE ALLOCATIONS FOR THE
BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM. THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT FOR EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION WITH ACROSS THERE
RIGHT ACROSS THEIR- THEIR
JURISDICTION AS WELL AND WE
HOPE THAT I WILL CREATE JUST
ONE MORE LAYER OF DISTRIBUTION
BETWEEN- CITIES AND CITIES AND
UNINCORPORATED AREAS WITHIN
WITHIN A COUNTY THAT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR THAT THAT
RESERVATION. AND THEN AS IT
RELATES TO- MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE OUR REACH WITHIN- WITHIN
SMALLER JURISDICTION- THAT'S
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE BEEN
VISION AT THE THIRD PARTY
IMPLEMENTOR WOULD BE- REQUIRED
TO HAVE A STRONG PARTNERSHIP ON
BOTH IN IN PLACE ALREADY AND
THEN. NEW PARTNERSHIP WITH
DOUBTLESS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE WAS A VERY LASER FOCUSED
ON I'M GETTING THE INFORMATION
INTO THE HANDS OF- OF
INDIVIDUALS ALL ACROSS THE
STATE AND ESPECIALLY IN THE
AREAS THAT ARE ARE- AT. HARD
HARDER TO REACH- FOR MANY
REASONS. SO IT SOUNDS LIKE IF
YOU HAD THE SAID ASID THE AND
MILLION FOR THESE CAN. THEY
WOULDN'T GOTTEN PROPORTION
MONEY RIGHT. THE WAY IT WAS SET
UP TO IF YOU HAD TO SET THAT
ASIDE CONSCIOUSLY. WHAT I
THOUGHT MIGHT HAPPEN WOULD
HAPPEN RIGHT. RIGHT BECAUSE OF
THE ALLOCATION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT YES BUT I BELIEVE
THAT WE CORRECTED FOR THAT AT
THE STATE LEVEL WITHIN THE
PROGRAM. OKAY THANK YOU. I
THINK YOU WERE GOING TO GO TO
SOMEONE MATHIS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I WANT TO ECHO IT
AND THINK- MY COLLEAGUE DR
WOODS FOR. HIS COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS FOR OUR ROLE AREAS I
SHARE MANY OF THOSE- AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE-
PROPORTION MEN OR EQUITY
QUESTION IN ENSURING THAT- WERE
ABLE TO GET. RESOURCES AND
FUNDING THERE BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE. COMES
INTO THE EFFICIENCY. ON HOW
THIS PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE
MEASURED- WE'VE SEEN A AND I
GET THESE CALLS ALL THE TIME I
MEAN ARE. THE TWO ONE ONE LINE
FOR GETTING HELP WITH
EVERYTHING GOING ON CONTINUES
TO CRASH. WE'VE SEEN STATE
WEBSITES FROM DMV EDT EVEN
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CONTINUE TO CRASH. AND I HAVE A
CONCERN THAT AS THIS ROLLS OUT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE. EVEN MORE
OF A PROBLEM KEEPING OUR BASIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE UP- ME IN
YET ANOTHER WEBSITE WILL CRASH-
IT'S NOT. SO IT IS MY FIRST
QUESTION WOULD BE WHAT IS GOING
TO BE DONE. TO ENSURE THAT THE
SYSTEMS DO NOT CRASH LIKE ALL
THE OTHERS- AS THIS PROGRAM
ROLLS OUT. CAN I ASK ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM AGENCY TO
RESPOND TO THAT. ABSOLUTELY.
YES THANK I CAN I CAN TAKE THAT
ERICA AND THAT IS A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION AND IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE AND-
REALLY RESEARCHING AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE LEARNING
LESSONS FROM AND EXPERIENCES
BOTH WITHIN THE STATE AND
WITHIN OTHER STATES ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES. AND WE THINK
pIS PROVIDE A METRIC WITHIN OUR
OUR WEBSITE PROGRAM. IT WOULD
REQUIRE- AT CERTAIN
REDUNDANCIES- REALLY LEAN ON
BEING ABLE TO LEAN ON ENACT A
NATIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO HAVE-
YOU KNOW THE RIGHT BACKBONE- TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE USE THAT
WE CAN IMAGINE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN I THINK THE OTHER
THING WE HAVE TO DO IS REALLY
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE SETTING UP
WITH THE- THE APPLICATION
PROCESS IN A WAY. THAT THAT
DOES NOT- YOU KNOW LEADERS AND
AN IMMEDIATE CRASH THE THINGS
YOU CAN DO FOR EXAMPLE WOULD
BE- HAVING A FIRST TO GAUGE
WHERE IF THE APPLICATION GO
THEN BUT YOU DON'T. YOU DON'T
UPLOAD DOCUMENTS AND SO LET ME.
THE ELEMENTS LIKE THAT RIGHT
RIGHT THERE THIS FOR THOSE OF
US IN AND RURAL AREAS- THE GIN
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE SAID. THERE
ISN'T A. UPLOAD ON TO THE
INTERNET. THERE IS A- VERY.
CONCERNED PERSON STRUGGLING TO
CALL A ONE EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER
FOR TWO ONE ONE. TO GET THROUGH
TO GET ASSISTANCE. SOME OF THEM
ESPECIALLY IN MY AREA IT'S A
HIGHLY TINO AREA DON'T EVEN
SPEAK ENGLISH. SO THEY'RE
THEY'RE CALLING TO GET HELP.
AND THEN BEING REDIRECTED TO A
WEBSITE WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET. BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD INTERNET. OR
THE THERE'S NOT ACCESS IN THAT
AREA BECAUSE IT'S SO FAR OUT IN
THE WHOLE ROLE BROADBAND ISSUE
AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT WE'RE
ALSO DEALING WITH. SO IS THERE
GOING TO BE A CALL CENTER SET
UP. IT'S ACTUALLY NOT GOING TO
FALL APART AND CRASH. SO OUR
PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY CALL IN
WHATEVER LANGUAGE THEY NEED TO
CALL IN WITH. TO GET HELP IN
SOMEBODY LIKE IN THAT CALL
CENTER THAT'S GOING TO FILL OUT
THIS APPLICATION FOR THEM- SO
THEY CAN RECEIVE THE CELL THEY
THAT IS ONE OF MY GREATEST
CONCERNS RIGHT NOW. BECAUSE
EVERYBODY THAT I TALKED TO ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL IS TELLING ME
THESE THINGS KEEP CRASHING. AND
EVEN FR THOSE THAT ARE TRYING
TO CALL WHEN. THEY I MEAN SOME
ARE PRIVATE SECTOR FOLKS IN IN
I KNOW YOU MENTIONED THE
PRIVATE SECTOR SIDE. BOY IS
THERE GOING TO BE A CALL CENTER
THAT'S GONNA WALK THESE PEOPLE
THROUGH THIS IN IN HOUSE STABLE
IS THAT GONNA BE. THANK YOU FOR
RENT. YES THERE'S GOING TO BE A
CALL CENTER TO GET THESE PEOPLE
HELP ME. YES THEY'RE GOING TO
BE A CALL CENTER TO GET PEOPLE
HELP- AND THE WAY THAT WE
ENVISION THAT THERE WOULD BE A
MULTILINGUAL CALL CENTER. WE
WOULD SET THE STANDARD FOR NO
MORE THAN A TEN MINUTE WAIT
TIME WITH THE CALL BACK
FEATURE. AND TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUAL HAD- PROMPTNESS IN
THEIR ROOF IN THE RESPONSE TIME
BUT ALSO UNCERTAINTY THAT THEY
WOULD BE CALLED BACK IF THE
CALL CRIME WAS LONGER THAN TEN
MINUTES. AND THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT PROVIDERS IN THE
MARKET THEY THAT- HANS SYSTEMS
THAT HAVE THEM YOU KNOW. UP TO
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES I'M AT A CALL CENTER
SO YOU CAN BE ABLE TO BE ROUTE
YOU CAN ROUTE THE CALLER TO
SOMEBODY WHO SPEAKS THE
LANGUAGE OF THEIR CHOICE. AND
CAN BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THEM AND
WORKING THROUGH THE APPLICATION
PROCESS I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT IT IS A
BIT USEFUL DON'T WHERE PART OF
THE SOLUTION AND- HAVING
THROUGH THE PROGRAM AND- I'M
INTEREST AS A THEORY OF
COMMUNITY BASED PARTNER. THAT
CAN ALSO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE-
MORE LOCALIZED- SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES TO THE INDIVIDUALS
ARE GOING THROUGH THAT PROCESS
WITH WELL. AND THEN THAT CAN
LOOK LIKE ANYTHING FROM YOU
KNOW- ACCESS ACCESS TO ACCESS
TO COMPUTERS ACT THE PARENTS.
WERE LIVING INDIVIDUALS YOU
HAVE ON THE MOBILE CAPABILITIES
TO BE ABLE TO HELP SOMEBODY
THAT THEIR APPLICATION. AND SO
YES THERE IS DEFINITELY A CALL
CENTER- ENVISIONED ENOUGH
ENOUGH. PROPOSAL- BUT THERE'S
ALSO A LOT MORE. OKAY IN THE MY
FIVE PLAN I HAVE FOR YOU. THE
IGGY THIS IS THE EFFICIENCY
QUESTION WHAT ARE THE
MEASUREMENTS OF SUCCESS THAT
YOU ALL ARE PUTTING FORWARD
WHAT WHAT IS YOUR SCORING
METRICS TO DETERMINE THAT THIS
IS ACTUALLY BEING EFFICIENT AND
WORKING SO WHEN IT WHEN PEOPLE
COME BACK YOU KNOW TWO WEEKS
AFTER THIS LAUNCHES A MONTH
AFTER THIS LAUNCHES X. CETERA
WHAT WHAT IS THAT SCORING
METRICS THAT YOU ALL HAVE
PREPARED TO JUDGE HOW WILL THIS
PROGRAMS WORKING SO WE KNOW
WHAT TO LOOK AT TO FIX IT ALONG
THE WAY. BECAUSE SO FAR WITHOUT
EVERY PROGRAM WE SEEN ROLLOUT
IN THE PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS
THERE THERE IS NO SCORING
METRICS THEY WERE NOT BEING
SHARED THE DATA- BUT WE'RE
LITERALLY NOT FINDING OUT
INFORMATION UNTIL IT'S IN THE
PRESS- AND IT'S VERY
FRUSTRATING FOR ALL THE MEMBERS
ACROSS THE BOARD SO I'M ASKING
YOU UP FRONT WHAT THAT METRICS
LOOKS LIKE SO AS A LEGISLATIVE
BODY SPECIALLY AS WELL COMING
INTO. BUDGETARY AND EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT WE KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
SCORING METRICS IS SO AS WE
START OUR BUDGET SESSIONS ARE
SUB COMMITTEES. WE KNOW WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT. SURE MISTER-
MATHIS AND THE INTEGRITY OF THE
PROGRAM IS REALLY IMPORTANT
OBVIOUSLY- THERE THERE ARE
TRUST ISSUES WE UNDERSTAND-
BASED ON. BASED ON OTHER OTHER
PROGRAMS AND SO ONE THING I
WOULD KNOW IS THAT OVERSIGHT-
PROVIDED. I HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE WE ARE ATTEMPTING-
TO HAVE MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
MARK MORE OVERSIGHT THERE WILL
BE MONTHLY RECORDINGS BUT
JUMPING SEE IN REGARDS TO
METRICS WHICH I WILL TURN OVER
TO MY- COLLEAGUES TO GIVE YOU
THE DETAILS EARNING BUT THE
THOSE MONTHLY- REPORTS ARE TO
HELP KEEP. YOU INFORMED AS WELL
AS OURSELVES IN PREPARATION.
FOR POTENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS OR
CHANGES OR THINGS THAT NEED TO
OCCUR AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WITH
THE TP A THIRD PARTY
IMPLEMENTOR- AS WE COLLECT
THOSE METRICS WE HOPE THAT THIS
IS AN INTERACTIVE PROCESS EVEN
THOUGH IT'S A IT'S A SHORT
DURATION IN TERMS OF PROGRAMS
THAT WERE ALWAYS GETTING BETTER
AND BEING INFORMED. NOT JUST BY
THE THINGS THAT CRISTINA LIKE
WITH THE PPP PROGRAM AND A
LESSONS LEARNED THERE BUT
LESSONS LEARNED- WITHIN THE
PROGRAM ITSELF AND SO I'M I'LL
TURN TO EITHER LAND OR ANY FOR
THE DETAILS REGARDING THE
METRICS THAT WILL BE COLLECTED
ENSURE THAT. THE LEGISLATURE IN
THOSE MONTHLY REPORT. THANK YOU.
SURE AND- ONE THING I WOULD
MENTION- VERY QUICKLY AS WELL
AS THAT THAT HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT WILL HAVE
A PROGRAM MANAGEMENT TEAM THAT
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR AND
THEY YOU KNOW THE ENTIRE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM
SO BOTH THE- THAT THIRD PARTY
IMPLEMENTOR COMPONENT AS WELL
AS THE MANAGEMENT OF THE BLOCK
GRAHAM- OF THE STATE QUESTION
THAT ARE ARE ISSUED TO YOU-
JURISDICTIONS THAT THAT BLACKED%
OUT BLOCK GRANTS AND THERE WILL
BE A COHESIVE CENTRAL POINT OUT
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT THAT OVERSEES THAT
THE HOLISTIC NATURE OF THIS
PROGRAM. AND IN TERMS OF THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND THEY
ARE SOLD OUT BY THE BY THE US
TREASURY AND THEY INCLUDE
INFORMATION ABOUT- B. AT THE
NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED AT THE
HAVE BEEN PROCESSED AND THEN
ALL OF THE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION AND DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION INCOME INFORMATION
GEOGRAPHIC INFORMATION ETCETERA
THAT ACCOMPANIES ALL OF THIS
APPLICATION I'M SO WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE CLOCK WILL BE
LOOKING AT IT BOTH FROM HE
CLIENT EXPERIENCE IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
SYSTEM. AND THE IMPLEMENTERS IN
A WAY THAT- IS IT HELPFUL
SIMPLE- AND THEN THAT YOU KNOW
HELP ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE
TRUCK THAT THEY MAY BE FEELING
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC- BUT THEM
ALTHOUGH WILL BE LOOKING AT IT
FROM A VERY QUANTITATIVE
PERSPECTIVE IN TERMS OF THE
RECORDINGTHAT TRACK- THAT ARE
BOTH REQUIRED THAT ARE REQUIRED
BY BY THE TREASURY AND WILL BE
MONITORING. THOSE ON A ON A
WEEKLY AND MONTHLY BASIS. OKAY
SO YOU'RE GOING TO LOOK AT.
QUALITY BUT- FOR QUANTITATIVE
VERSUS. THE MEAN. IT'S WOULD.
DO YOU ACTUALLY HAVE. THE
METRICS LAID OUT WHEN ARE WE
GETTING A COPY OF THAT IS- JUST
SIMPLY SAYING OH WE'RE GONNA
FOLLOW WHAT THE FEDS SAY I MEAN
THAT THAT'S FANTASTIC BUT- WHEN
ARE YOU GOING TO SPELL THAT OUT
SO THE PUBLIC ACTUALLY KNOWS.
WHAT THAT METRIX'S. SURE SURE
HE- YES THAT'S ALL OF THE
DIMENSIONAL BE SHARED PENDING
ON THE B. AT THIS BUILDING
ENACTED- WE WOULD THEN GO
THROUGH A VERY RAPID ON
PROGRAM- COMPLETION WHERE WE
WOULD DO THE FULL PROGRAM
DESIGN AND ENSURE THAT ALL OF
THE- THE STRUCTURES- THE
STRUCTURE IS VERY CLEAR WE
WOULD DO A FULL ROLLOUT WE
WOULD EXPLAIN ALL THE PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS WORK WITH ALL OF
THE PARTICIPATING PARTIES AND
THAT INFORMATION AT ALL THE
PUBLIC AND THAT MEANT MUCH MOST
OF THAT AS IT STANDING
COMPLETION. I SEE I THINK THAT
BILL BEFORE IT ROLLS OUT SO
EVERYBODY CAN SEE WHAT'S GOING
ON IT VERSUS AFTER YOU GET YOUR
FIRST. ROUND TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE THING YOU WERE
GOING TO GO TO MISTER. BUT
THERE AGO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR- YOU KNOW WE HAVE A REALLY
CHALLENGING PROBLEM IN FRONT OF
US- AND- THINK ABOUT THREE
MAJOR ISSUES WE HAVE A DEADLINE
FOR TENANT PROTECTIONS THAT IN
FRONT OF US WE HAVE THE
FEDERAL- REQUIREMENTS IN TERMS
OF THE OF THE FUNDING THAT
THEY'RE SENDING US- IN ADDITION
TO THAT AS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU
POINTED OUT. WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF UNKNOWNS AND SO I REALLY
WANT TO- APPRECIATE AND
CONGRATULATE THE LEADERSHIP-
THE MAJORITY LEADER REYES AND
OF PARTICULAR HOUSING CHAIR
CHIU- FOR COMING UP WITH REALLY
INTELLIGENT AND CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO MANY OF THE
CHALLENGES- THAT ARE IN FRONT
OF US AND ALL OF THE OTHER
PEOPLE THAT- MR CHU IDENTIFIED
AT THE BEGINNING OF. OF HIS
COMMENTS SO- OVERALL- THIS IS A
GOOD PROGRAM AND IT WORKS- MY
COMMENTS ARE. SIMPLY THAT-
THERE ONE AREA I HOPE THAT IT
MERITS FURTHER ATTENTION AS WE
ARE TRYING TO EVALUATE THIS
BETWEEN NOW AND JUNE WHEN THIS
EXPIRES- IS THAT THE TENANT.
NOTIFICATION WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT IT ATTENDANT WHO IS
BEHIND IN THEIR RENT. IS
COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED WITH
LOTS OF THINGS IN LIFE AND THE
IDEA THAT THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
MONITOR WHETHER THEIR LANDLORD
APPLIED. AND NOW DO THEY GET TO
APPLY THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND THAT JUST WHEN THE TIRE
MEETS THE ROAD THAT'S GOING TO
BE THE REAL DIFFICULT THING FOR
THE TEST. THEY HAVE PERHAPS A
LOCAL- TENANT PROTECTION
ORDINANCE IN PLACE THAT THEY
WILL CONFUSE WITH THE STATE
SENATE PROTECTION- THAT IS IN
PLACE AND THEN THEY HAVE ALL OF
THESE OTHER. THINGS TO FOR
NOTIFICATION SELF. HI I'M THIS
IS NOT A CRITICISM AT ALL I
WOULD VERY MUCH APPRECIATE WHAT
WAS CREATED HERE. IT IS AN
ALERT THAT I HOPE WE CAN WATCH
THAT AS WE'RE TRYING TO GATHER
THE FEEDBACK BOTH WITH THE
STAFF AND- CERTAINLY WITH ALL
THE LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOT GONNA MISTER KILEY. A
GOOD MORNING I WANT TO PICK UP
ON AN ANSWER YOU GAVE IN
RESPONSE ONE OF MR MATHIS IS
QUESTIONS ABOUT LOOKING THE
OTHER STATES WHEN IT COMES TO
SOME OF THE I. T. ISSUES- SINCE
YOU KNOW ALL THE STATES ARE IN
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME POSITION
WITH RESPECT TO THIS NEW
FEDERAL PROGRAM I'D IMAGINE
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
APPROACH IS BEING WORKED OUT.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY I COULD YOU
TELL ME A LITTLE BIT ABOUT. HOW
YOU'VE WORKED WITH OTHER STATES
TRIED TO LOOK FOR BEST
PRACTICES THAT ARE BEING
ADOPTED ELSEWHERE. WHEN THANK
YOU YEAH AND REMEMBER KILEY
THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE DONE A WONDERFUL JOB OF
BRINGING ALL THE STATE TOGETHER
AND TO BE ABLE TO DISCUSS-
DISCUSS THE NEEDS THAT ISSUES
INVOLVED- SHARE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THEIR
STATE I'M SO THAT'S BEEN ONE OF
THE PRIMARY RATE THAT WE HAVE
BEEN CONNECTED- THROUGH
NATIONAL AND NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN BE IN
THE STATE TOGETHER AND THEN WE
HAVE ALSO HAD A NUMBER OF THE
STATE TO STATE- CALL WITH AND
OTHER STATES THAT SHARE THANK
CHARACTERISTICS ARE CONCERNED
THAT. POPULATION AND COMPLEXITY.
OKAY WELL I YEAH I'M ENCOURAGED
TO HEAR THAT AND I DIDN'T
COURAGE THOSE CONVERSATIONS TO
CONTINUE BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
QUITE FRANKLY CALIFORNIA HAS
NOT PERFORMED WELL. IN MANY
DIMENSIONS OF THIS COVERT
RESPONSE COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES IN THE COUNTRY I HAVE A
QUOTE HERE FROM SENATOR SCOTT
WIENER OF SAN FRANCISCO. WHO
SAYS I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
ADMINISTRATIVE ROLE OUT OF RENT
RELIEF GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S
LOGISTICAL PROBLEMS DURING THE
PANDEMIC PANDEMIC WITH THINGS
LIKE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. AND
VACCINES AND OF COURSE WE COULD
HAVE ADDED A WHOLE HOST OF
OTHER THINGS WERE CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN AMONG THE WORST STATES
IN THE COUNTRY SO. YOU KNOW
AND- WE SAW FOR EXAMPLE WITH
THE EDT FRAUD ISSUE THE DA'S
THERE SO JUST LOOK WHAT OTHER
STATES ARE DOING. THEY FIGURED
OUT SO I JUST HEARD THE
ADMINISTRATION. JUST TO LOOK AT
STATES THAT HAVE DONE A GOOD
JOB WITH THINGS LIKE THIS AND
COPY WHAT THEY'RE DOING
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW IF OUR OWN
SOLUTIONS ENDED UP WORKING OUT
WELL. ON THIS ISSUE WOULD BE A
DRAMATIC BREAK FROM PRECEDENT
WITH ALL OF THE OTHER ISSUES.
THAT WE FACED RECENTLY. SECOND
POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS THAT-
YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT RELIEF WHICH A LOT OF
FOLKS. ABSOLUTELY NEED. BUT
WHEN YOU REALLY TALK TO PEOPLE
WHAT THEY WANTED THEY WANTED
NOT NECESSARILY RELIEF FROM THE
GOVERNMENT THEY WANT TO BE ABLE
TO EARN A PAYCHECK AGAIN. AND
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD THE MOST
STRINGENT RESTRICTIONS ON WORK
OF ANY STATE. IN THE COUNTRY.
AND BY THE WAY THAT EXISTED
EVEN BEFORE- THE LOCKDOWNS
WE'VE THE ONLY STATE IN THE
BAND INDEPENDENT CONTRACTING.
FOR EXAMPLE AND ON TOP OF ALL
THAT WE'RE NOT GETTING PEOPLE
THE UNEMPLOYMENT CHECKS THAT
THEY NEED. AT LEAST WITH
RESPECT TO THE LATTER THE
LEGISLATURE'S PROVIDED SOME
MODICUM OF OVERSIGHT BUT IT
HASN'T SOLVED ANY OF THE
PROBLEMS THE BACKLOG IS ABOUT
AS- LARGE AS HAVE BEEN. AND SO
I WOULD JUST- ENCOURAGE THIS
COMMITTEE THIS LEGISLATURE TO
TAKE A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN
TRYING TO ACT QUICKLY ALLOW
PEOPLE TO GET BACK TO WORK. AND
THEN THE PROBLEMS WE'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE HERE I WOULD NOT
NEARLY BE AS MUCH OF AN
OBSTACLE OR IS L. OR IS THAT AS
BIG AS THE- AS THEY ARE. AS AYE
AYE THE CONCERNS OF THE MEMBERS
MAKE CLEAR SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO MEMBER S. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER WHY WE'RE
HERE- WE'RE TRYING TO EXTEND
SOMETHING THAT WAS PUT TOGETHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TRUE IN AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT WITH
HOMELESS MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND FINALLY GOT AS
AN EXTENSION FOR OUR TENANTS SO
THAT THEY CAN AVOID EVICTION
WHEN THAT WAS PUT TOGETHER
THERE WAS NO REAL PROTECTION
FOR THE LANDLORDS WERE ASKING
THE LANDLORDS JUST TO WAIT. NOW
THAT WE RECEIVED TWO POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE NOW GET
TO EXTEND THAT MORATORIUM. PUT
IN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO AN AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT BUT NOW WE
ALSO GET TO TELL THE LANDLORDS
NOW YOU'RE PART OF THE EQUATION
YOU HELD OFF. ON GETTING YOUR
ROUNDS NOW WE'RE GOING TO PUT
TOGETHER A PROGRAM AND FIGURE
OUT HOW WE GET TO GIVE YOU SOME
OF YOUR MONEY. 80% IF THEY
ACCEPT THAT. THEY HAVE TO WRITE
IT OFF THE TENANT NO LONGER HAS
TO ALSO ANY LATE FEES ANY OTHER
FEES THAT WOULD BE THE END OF
IT. AND THEN HOPEFULLY THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO PAY THE RENT
THERE AFTER WE WOULD STILL BE
ABLE TO UNDER THE PROGRAM. HELP
THEM WITH THE 25% THE THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT ARE PUT
INTO SB NINETY ONE AND I THINK
THAT. IT STRIKES A GOOD
BALANCE. THAT'S INTENDED TO.
PREVENT THAT WAVE OF EVICTIONS
THAT ARE OTHERWISE GOING TO
DEVASTATE OUR COMMUNITIES.
FEBRUARY ONE WE WOULD IF WE
DON'T HAVE THIS FEBRUARY ONE
BEGIN THE EVICTIONS SO WE'RE-
FINALLY ABLE TO REACH SOME SORT
OF A BALANCE. AND IN PERFECT
BALANCE I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO THOSE WERE THE FIRST HIS
FIRST COMMENTS AND I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH HIM IT'S IN PERFECT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE HAS TALKED
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS. I
ALSO. I APPRECIATE THAT IN SB
NINETY ONE- IT NOT ONLY DOES IT
EXTEND TO THE FICTION
MORATORIUM BUT IT ALSO TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT. THE MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES- THAT BECAUSE OF
THE IS THIS PANDEMIC THE
CUPBOARD NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
THIS IS DONE THROUGH THE
PROGRAM PRIORITIZATION
PROVISIONS UNDER THE STATE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. SO
THOSE MOST DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED ARE GOING TO BE THE
FIRST TO RECEIVE THESE
BENEFITS. AND I WOULD CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO. UNDER THE- THE
VALUATION OF THE ANALYSIS THAT
WAS DONE IT'S UNDER THE LETTER
YOU PROGRAM PRIORITIZATION. THE
FACT THAT THE PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTERS REQUIREMENT
INCLUDES THAT THEY ALSO HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
LEVEL PARTNERS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITIES LIKE THOSE IN AND
DOCTOR WORDS AND MISSED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS BECAUSE
MANY OF THOSE RENTERS HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO PAY THE RENT SINCE
MARCH OF LAST YEAR THEY'VE
ALREADY COMMUNICATE WITH
SOMEBODY IN THOSE ARE USUALLY
IN THE COMMUNITY. SO THE FACT
THAT THIS AGREEMENT THIS BILL
IS GOING TO REQUIRE THAT
WHOEVER IS GOING TO BE IN
CHARGE HAS THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. THE THIS IS GOING TO
HELP OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES
INCENTIVIZING OUR LANDLORDS TO
ACCEPT THE 80% WAS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE INPUT
FORM FROM FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHIU HIS BECAUSE HE HAS WORKED
FOR SO LONG ON THIS ISSUE HIS
INPUT HIS LEADERSHIP HERE WAS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. HAVING
SPEAKER RENDON TAKE THIS ON
IMMEDIATELY AS THE WELL AS AS
WELL AS THE PRO TEM ATKINS WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THIS WAS
TOO SMALL TO LARGE TO ALLOW IT
TO JUST GO THROUGH A PROCESS TO
HELP OUR THREE LEADERS SAY THIS
IS TOP PRIORITY WE'VE GOT TO
COME UP WITH SOMETHING I'M
REALLY PROUD OF THAT AND-
GRATEFUL THAT I WAS ABLE TO
JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU. IN
SOME OF THESE STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS. MY QUESTION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION IS THIS. I
BOUNDS WITH SO MANY OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT COME AND WHEN
THEY GOAL WELL. WE'RE ALL HAPPY
WHEN THEY DON'T IT IS OUR
OFFICES TO RECEIVE THE CALLS IT
IS OUR OFFICES IT IS OUR STAFF
WHO THEN HAVE TO. TO TRY TO DO
THE RESEARCH FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS. WILL THE
ADMINISTRATION BE WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH PROVIDING. THEM
PROVIDE CONTINUOUS INFORMATION
TO THAT ARE LEGISLATIVE OFFICES
TO ASSIST US IN TAKING CARE OF
THE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS AND
NEEDS OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
EARLIER IN REGARDS TO REPORTING
THERE WILL BE THE MONTHLY
REPORTING TO THE COMMITTEE- BUT
I WILL TRY THIS QUESTION OVER
TO WINNER AMY IN REGARDS TO
DISTRICT OFFICES AND THE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN. THE
ADMINISTRATION AND DISTRICT
OFFICES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. YES
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- I.
I'M THE LEGISLATIVE DEPUTY AT A
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AND- SO I THAT WE DO
HAVE A LOT OF INTERACTION- BOTH
WITH NOT ONLY WITH LEADERSHIP
STAFF BUT WITH DISTRICT. AND TO
CAPITOL OFFICES WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE QUESTIONS GENERALLY
SPEAKING- AND ARE SUBJECT AREA
AND- I WOULD SAY- OUT NGUYEN AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT WAS ENACTED
WE OUT WORKED CLOSELY WITH A
LEADERSHIP STAFF TO- SET UP A
NUMBER OF TRAININGS- SEMINAR
TYPE TRAININGS- WITH- BOTH
CAPITAL AND DISTRICT OFFICE
STAFF TO MAKE SURE THEY
UNDERSTOOD- BOTH THE ELEMENTS.
OF THE LAW BUT ALSO ALL THE
RESOURCES THAT THE STATE WAS
MAKING AVAILABLE INFORMATIONAL
RESOURCES AND HOW TO CONNECT
WITH LEGAL AID IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES- AND- OTHER OTHER-
AT. WAYS TO. MAKE SURE THAT-
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT THEIR
CONSTITUENTS WERE UNDERSTANDING
OF BOTH THE- PROTECTIONS AND
THE OBLIGATIONS OF AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT AND- SO WE
ENVISION SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR
WITH THIS AS WELL- BUT OF
COURSE WE HAVE. THE ADDED
ELEMENT OF THE FINANCIAL
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
AND- SO WE WILL BE- YOU KNOW
PREPARING TO DO THAT AS WELL
THE SAME KIND OF OUR REGION
EDUCATION TO- CAPITAL AND
DISTRICT OFFICES. AND WE REALLY
SEE- YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY
DISTRICT OFFICES IS BEING
WONDERFUL AMBASSADORS FOR THE
PROGRAM- AND- YOU KNOW HELPING.
TO SURFACE ISSUES AND CONCERNS-
SO THAT WE GET- ALSO FEEDBACK
THAT WE CAN INCORPORATE INTO
THE IMPLEMENTATION. THANK.
THANK YOU DOCTOR DOCTOR WHAT.
YES THANK YOU I JUST HAVE I
JUST HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
I YOU KNOW- I HEARD A NOTE 95%
OF FOLKS LIVE IN URBAN AREAS-
5% OF FOLKS LIVE IN RURAL
AREAS- THIRTY COUNTIES ARE LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND IN
POPULATION THIRTY OF OUR FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES- I'M LOOKING AT
HERE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT YOUR
PERMIT. THE PROGRAM IMPLEMENTER
REQUIREMENTS IT SOUNDS LIKE
THIS IS ONE PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTER. HOW DO YOU DO YOU
ARE THERE OTHER PROGRAM INTO
IMPLEMENTERS THAT WORK
DIRECTLY. IS THIS ALL. BIG
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTOR GOING TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE ALL THESE
RELATIONSHIPS YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT OR ARE THERE OTHER
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTERS IT WILL BE
WORKING AND OTHER KEY AND IN
SMALLER COUNTIES. YES
ABSOLUTELY SO THE WAY THAT
ENVISIONED ABOUT THE THAT
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT WOULD HAVE ONE
CENTRAL CONTRACT WITH THE
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTER AND THEN
THAT PROGRAM IMPLEMENTER WOULD
WORK WITH. NUMBER OF LOCAL DAY
PARTNER THAT WOULD PROVIDE
VARIOUS LEVELS OF SUPPORT AND
CHANGE YOU INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES DIRECTLY- THE IDEA
BEING THAT THE AD THE
DECENTRALIZATION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR COMMUNICATION OUR
REGION TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
BUT THAT THE UNIFICATION OF THE
APPLICATION MATERIAL INSIDE OF
THE- THE CENTRAL PORTAL IS WHAT
ALLOWS US TO BE ABLE TO MANAGE
THAT THAT THE CONTENT AND THAT
THE PROGRAM RESOURCES IN A WAY
THAT THE MOST EFFECTIVE. THOUGH
YES THERE WOULD BE THERE WOULD
BE A NUMBER OF- I DIRECT DIRECT
PROGRAM. PROVIDES PARTNERSHIP
THAT WOULD BE LOCATED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BUT THEN
THEY WOULD LINK. UP TO THE
CENTRAL IMPLEMENTOR. SO-
LOGISTICALLY I OUT I DO I DON'T
JUST AN IBM I'M NOT SURE TO BE
TO I'M REALLY NOT A NEVER GONNA
APOLOGIZE BEING PASS. IN MICE.
OF MY CONSTITUENTS FOR THE FIVE
COUNTIES ARE REPRESENTED LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE. AND AND I AND I DO HAVE
CONCERNS I JUST I JUST. WORRY
THAT. WE'RE GONNA BE
POTENTIALLY YOU KNOW NOT NOT
SEE THAT- SEEM TO SEE THE SAME
SUCCESS. BECAUSE EVERY TO
WONDER ABOUT THE METRICS AND
HOW THE METRICS WILL FLOW AND I
HOPE THAT AS WE START GETTING
INFORMATION BACK THAT IT WILL
ALSO BE ON A COUNTY BY COUNTY
BASIS SO WE CAN REALLY JUDGE
THE SUCCESS. OF WHAT'S GOING ON
BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW
95% OF PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE INTERNET ACCESS WHAT WHAT
THAT DOESN'T TELL YOU IS THAT'S
NOT 95% IN EVERY COUNTY THAT'S
95% STATEWIDE. AND WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT OFTEN SMALLER
COUNTIES ARE RURAL COUNTIES ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE JUST
PROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED AND SO
I HOPE THAT THE METRICS THEY
WERE LOOKING AT. ARE GOING TO
BE SUCCESSFUL FOR. THE HIGH
PERCENTAGE IN EVERY COUNTY AND
NOT JUST THAT 95% NUMBER
BECAUSE IF IT IS. WE LIVES AND
I AND I AND THAT'S THAT'S JUST
NOT FAIR. IT IF I MAY FOLLOW UP
AND MAYBE I CAN EXPLAIN ONE
OTHER THING THAT I THINK MAYBE
WILL HELP ALLEVIATE SOME OF
THAT CONCERN. AND THE WAY THAT
IT'S BEEN VISION WITHIN THE-
THAT THAT 5% IS THAT THERE
WOULD BE A RESERVATION FOR EACH
COUNTY. ON THAT UNDER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND SO AND- AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT BOTH
DISTRIBUTION OF RESOURCES AND
THEN THE COMMUNICATION OUR
REGION TECHNICAL. GEN IT WILL
ALL BE TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND
RESOURCES- THAT ALLOCATE THAT
RESERVATION TABLE. UNTIL EACH
JURISDICTION WILL WILL BE
MONITORING FOR EXPENDITURE
REYES. AND TARGETING SPENDING.
TO THAT TO THAT POINT. OUR
THERE HOLD BACK FRIEDMAN IS TO
THE STATE ON THAT WERE THAT IS
FOR THE IS THAT MONEY JUST
GOING TO BE THAT ENTIRE AMOUNT
GOING TO BE GOING OUT. IN OTHER
WORDS IS THERE A MIDDLE IS
THERE SORT OF A MIDDLE MAN
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE. THAT MEANS
THAT THE COUNTIES DON'T
ESSENTIALLY GET ALL OF THAT
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THURMOND ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
TO BEING ABLE TO RENOUNCE THE
PROGRAM- THAT- WE THINK THAT BY
DOING IT MORE CENTRALLY LOCATED
WE CAN FIND THE LAST. TIME
BRITAIN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ALLOW FOR. SO IT COULD BE UP TO
TEN PERCENT. THAT OF THAT
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT DOESN'T REALLY GO TO THOSE
COUNTIES IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. THAT IS AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE FEDERAL PROGRAM BUT
IT IS NOT WHAT WE ENVISION THE
COST STRUCTURE WITH AND I THINK.
BUT IF YOU'RE LARGER COUNTY
WHICH YOU WOULD NEVER MIND I
THINK YOU SEE MY POINT. IT'S A
DIRECT ALLOCATION TO LARGER
COUNTIES BUT- SMALLER COUNTIES
THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE A HARDER
TIME. MAKE MAY LOSE. UP 210% OF
HOPE DOESN'T HAPPEN BUT THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY WHAT YOU WHAT YOU
SAID SO. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER FOR. I JUST A
QUICK CLARIFICATION- TO THE
POINT THAT- THAT SOME MEMBER
WHAT MADE SO IS IT.
JURISDICTIONS UNDER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND SO IS THAT WOULD BE
COUNTIES AND CITIES OR IS IT
JUST COUNTIES AND IT WOULD FLOW
FROM THE COUNTY TO THE UP THE
JURISDICTIONS UNDERNEATH GUY
I'D MET MAYBE CAN PLEASE
CLARIFY FOR ME. WHO WITH THE
RESERVATION WOULD IT BE. I FOR
EXAMPLE KERN COUNTY WOULD GO TO.
THE CITY OF TEHACHAPI OR
DIRECTLY WITH THE TAXI ATTACHED
WE HAVE TO APPLY OR WOULD IT GO
TO THE COUNTY IN THE COUNTY
WOULD ALLOCATE THE MONEY TO THE
CITY TAX BE. ALLOCATION
QUESTION. SO FOR THE- THE
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE IN THE
UNDER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND-
ACTION AND THERE'S NOT ACTUALLY
A PHYSICAL TRANSFER OF MONEY TO
THE COUNTY AT THAT THEIR THEIR
RESERVATION BASED OFF OF THE
POPULATION THAT THAT AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL BUT THEN THE
APPLICATION BUT THEN THE FUNDS
ARE DISTRIBUTED TO THE
INDIVIDUAL APPLICANTS. OKAY SO
THE CITIES WITHIN THE CITIES-
SMALL CITIES WITHIN THE COUNTY
WITH AND APPLY. FOR THAT THE
PERSON THE GRANT THE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS- FUNDING-
ELIGIBLE FOR THE GRANTS. AND SO
THE LANDLORD AND TENANT WOULD
APPLY- AND THEN THEY'RE IF
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE AND THEN THEY
MEET THAT CRITERIA THEN THERE
PAYMENT WOULD BE ACTUALLY
DEDUCTED FROM THE RESERVATION
FOR THAT COUNTY. WITH THE
COUNTY IN THE CITY SO THAT SO
THE SPEECH WOULD PROMOTE THE
GROUND WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION AND IN THE LOOP
THE LANDLORDS AND TENANTS
UNDERNEATH AND IN THE CITIES
THEY WOULD THEN APPLY THAT THAT
WOULD BE DEDUCTED FROM. THEIR A
RESERVATION ABOUT. THAT'S
CORRECT YES OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MISS CAREER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'M ALSO HERE TO GIVE TESTIMONY.
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY ONE. AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK THE- COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
AS WELL AS WELL AS LEADERSHIP
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR
WORKING SO DILLON DILIGENTLY ON
ON THIS VERY ISSUE. OUR STATE
IS TAKING A MONUMENTAL STEP
TODAY TO PROTECT FAMILIES FROM
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING
INSTABILITY. AN IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS BY EXTENDING THE
UNIVERSAL OF ACTION MORATORIUM
THROUGH JUNE THIRTIETH OF THIS
YEAR. CALIFORNIA'S COBIT OF
ACTION PROTECTIONS ARE THE
STRONGEST STATEWIDE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY I WAS PROUD TO HAVE CO
AUTHORED AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT
LAST YEAR LEGISLATION THAT
EXTENDED PROTECTIONS TO TENANTS
AND HOMEOWNERS ON OF IT UNABLE
TO MAKE THEIR RENT OR MORTGAGE
OR MORTGAGE PAYMENTS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WITHOUT IT WE WOULD
HAVE SEEN EVICTED FAMILIES BY
THOUSANDS FORCED TO TURN TO
SHELTERS THAT ARE ALREADY AT
CAPACITY. CROWDING THE HOMES OF
FAMILY AND FRIENDS SLEEPING IN
CARS AND ON THE STREETS. AND
PERHAPS EVEN BRING BACK THE
MORTGAGE. FORECLOSURE CRISIS
THAT WE SAW A FEW YEARS AGO.
OUR NEW AGREEMENT IS NOT
PERFECT BUT IT EXTENDS THE
EVICTION MORATORIUM OF IN
CALIFORNIA. UNTIL JUNE OF THIS
YEAR PROTECTING TENANTS AND
SMALL LANDLORDS FROM LOSING
THEIR HOUSING INSTABILITY AS
THE NATION CONTINUES. TO
CONFRONT THIS PANDEMIC. IT IS
ALL IT ALSO SEEKS TO MOVE
FORWARD AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
IN THE DEPLOYMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S SHARE OF THE
LATEST FEDERAL STIMULUS BILL.
ENSURING THAT UP TO TWO POINT
SIX BILLION AND RENTER AID IS
ADMINISTERED WITH EQUITY.
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ACCOUNTABILITY. OUR CHARGE IN
THIS BODY IS TO ENSURE THAT
THESE FEDERAL DOLLARS WILL BE
TARGETED TO THE MOST ADDRESS
HOUSEHOLDS. AND WITH UNPAID
BACK RENT AND WILL HELP TENANTS
STAY AFLOAT DURING AND AFTER
THE PANDEMIC. INCOME QUALIFIED
TENANTS IN THERE LANDLORDS CAN
CHOOSE TO RECEIVE DIRECT RENTAL
ASSISTANCE IN EXCHANGE FOR
GIVING PRIORAT PRIOR RENTAL
DEBT. THE AFFECTION MORATORIUM
AND RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF THESE
FEDERAL FUNDS TO MEET. THE MOST
AT RISK OUR OUR FIRST STEPS ARE
NEXT UP STEPS MUST BE TO TACKLE
THE HOUSING CRISIS. HOUSING
COSTS AS WELL AS HOMELESSNESS
AND THE HOUSES CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE PANDEMIC
EXACERBATED THESE CRISIS WHICH
WE KNOW ALREADY EXISTED. I
DON'T WANT TO GLOSS OVER THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
AND I'M CAUTIOUS AND WORRIED
THAT THIS PROGRAM IN THE
TECHNOLOGY BEING USED IS
ACTUALLY NOT AVAILABLE TO THE
MOST NEEDIEST OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. IF YOU ARE
SOMEBODY WITH THE LANGUAGE
BARRIER. WHO DOES NOT
UNDERSTAND TECHNOLOGY OR DOES
NOT HAVE SOMEONE IN THEIR
FAMILY TO GUIDE THEM HOW WILL
YOU ACCESS. AN INTERNET PORTAL
THAT YOU NEVER EVEN HEARD OF.
THAT YOU DON'T KNOW HOW TO
ACCESS SO MY QUESTION TODAY IS
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE TRUSTED PARTNERS
AND COMMUNITIES MOST WITH NEED.
THE CAN ALSO HELP FACILITATE
THIS PROCESS AND HOW THE
TECHNOLOGY BEING USE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ARE LOOKING AROUND
TO SEE ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PIETERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH- THE
HEART OF THIS ISSUE IS THAT WE
WANT TO KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR
HOMES HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS.
MY PARENTS LOST THEIR HOME IN
THE LAST HOUSING CRISIS AND I
WOULDN'T WISH THAT EXPERIENCE
ON MY WORST ENEMY. WHAT WHAT
EXACTLY IS BEING DONE TO HELP
HOMEOWNERS LIVING IN THEIR
HOMES THEY'RE ALSO UNEMPLOYED
AND UNABLE TO PAY THEIR
MORTGAGES FORBEARANCES ARE
GREAT BUT THEY STILL OWE THAT
MONEY AT THE END OF THE LOAN
WITH INTEREST ARE WE SETTING
ASIDE ANY OF ANY FEDERAL FUNDS
TO HELP WHEN THEM WITH THEIR
MOUNTING DEBTS AND WHY WAS IT
EXCLUDED IN THIS PROPOSAL AND
ISN'T THE KEY WORD HERE EQUITY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. YES THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AND THIRD
STATE PROGRAM IS BASED ON THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS WHICH IS
ON RENTAL ARREARS AND
LANDLORDS- AS I STATED BEFORE
THERE WAS A THERE'S AN
EXTENSION OF. FORBEARANCE AND
THE FEDERAL RELIEF SO I BELIEVE
SO TOO MARCH- BUT THERE ARE AND
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL EXTENSION
OF. DEADLINES WITHIN STATE
PROGRAM- REGARDING FOR PARENTS
AS WELL AND- THE REQUESTS- IF
THERE ARE ISSUES WITHIN IN THE
CASE OF OUR CLASS TO BEING
DENIED- THERE'S ADDITIONAL DAYS
AND ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT
MUST BE PROVIDED BY THOSE
BANKS. BUT THE SPECIFIC-
PROGRAM ITSELF IS FOR
ADDRESSING RENTAL ARREARS AND
YOU. S. FOR VENTURE. FOR SO
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO FUNDS
STATE- FOR AVAIL FOR HOMEOWNER
TO HELP PAY DOWN THEIR DEBT.
I'M THERE'S NOT IN THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM I WOULD TURN
IT OVER TO LAND OR ANY HAVE ANY
OTHER DETAILS. ON I DO- FOR
HOMEOWNERS ONE PROGRAM THAT AND
I WOULD LIKE TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION HERE IS THE NATIONAL
MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT PROGRAM
THAT'S BEING ADMINISTERED
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY. AND SO THAT WAS
THAT THOSE WE CAN POINT WHERE
PROGRAM AND LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
AND- KALENJIN FAYE IS CURRENTLY
RUNNING A- A- AS A FINANCIAL-
SERVICE COUNSELING PROGRAM
RIGHT NOW TO BE ABLE TO HELP
DISTRESSED MORTGAGE HOLDERS.
AND THEY'RE GETTING READY TO
LAUNCH THE SECOND PHASE OF THAT
PROGRAM- IN YOU KNOW THE COMING
IN THE COMING MONTHS. THAT WILL
THEN PROVIDE MORTGAGE
ASSISTANCE. TO HOMEOWNERS BOB.
THANK YOU. FOR THANK YOU I'M
LOOKING AROUND TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE BEFORE WE MOVE
OVER TO PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY
SEEING NONE LET'S GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE CHAMBER. NOTHING
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT THE CHAMBER
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE PHONE LINE. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
PEOPLE THAT HAVE. ALREADY FOR
COMMENT AND WE HAVE MORE COMING
UP THIS TIME. OKAY SOLUTION A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
THE FIRST COMMENT ON THE LINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY TWO HE SAID. YES SIR
OKAY THANK YOU MARTY A MOTO- A
FAMILY MEMBER- CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SENIOR COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK TV CAN'T JUST
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR FOR DOING THIS
STRONG SUPPORT FOR BOTH BILLS
DEPICTION PEACE AND- THE STATE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WILL
BE A TREMENDOUS HELP. TO TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND SENIOR
CENTER FAMILIES BUT ALSO REALLY
IMPORTANTLY THOUSANDS OF LOW
INCOME DIRECT CARE WORKERS
INCLUDING REGIONAL CENTER
SUPPORT LIVING SERVICES AND I
JUST SAYS. LOOK FOR WORKING
WITH THE IN THE COMING MONTHS-%
FOR LONGER TERM SOLUTIONS BUT.
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS THANK YOU. IT'S ONE
NOW GO TO LINE ELEVEN. LINE
ELEVEN ONE THOUSAND. A. B.
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA WANTS TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE MEASURE AND
APPRECIATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION AND STAFF ARE
WORKING TO PUT THAT TOGETHER
THIS IS GOING TO PROVIDE A
NORMAL THREE ASSIGNED TO
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE FACING POTENTIAL EVICTION
AT THE END OF THE MONTH. MANY
OF WHOM ARE MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT
MINE ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO ARE
EXHAUSTED AND TIRED FROM
WORKING DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
THEN HAVE TO GO HOME AT NIGHT
AND WORRY ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE GOING TO BE AFFECTED
AT THE END OF THE MONTH- THIS
BILL INCLUDES ADDITIONAL
PROTECTION IN THE BATH AND
BEYOND WHAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
ORIGINAL THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT-
OF WHICH ONE MUST APPRECIATE
HAVE- BUT WE DO WANT TO STRESS
THE FACT THAT THIS IS NOT A
PERMANENT SOLUTION AND IT'S NOT
A PERFECT SOLUTION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD. TO CONTINUING OUR WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CORRECT
EXISTING IMBALANCES THE KNACK
AND INEQUITIES IN THE CURRENT
LENTHALL. CUSTOM THANK YOU.
WELL NOW GOOD ALLY FIFTEEN LINE
TOOK. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IT
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SAID THIS IS CHRIS
WHITE SAKE WITH THE WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION AND WE
REPRESENT MORE THAN HALF OF THE
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES AND THE STATE. W.
MAY WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON A. B. AB OR SB
NINETY ONE YET AND BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE ON THESE MEASURES. AS YOU
NO MANUFACTURED HOUSING
REPRESENTS A SAFE SECURE AND
AFFORDABLE OPTION FOR HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. IN OUR MEMBERS-
FRANKLY IN THE BUSINESS OF
PROVIDING HOUSING. WE DON'T
WANT TO AFFECT PEOPLE. DOING SO
DOESN'T HELP A RESIDENT IT
DOESN'T HELP AN OWNER. THAT'S
WHY MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
RESIDENTS AFFECTED BY CODED
NINETEEN TO REMAIN IN THEIR
HOMES. MOST OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES THEY'VE BEEN
VESTED THEIR LIFE SAVINGS AND
PROVIDING HOUSING OPTIONS FOR
FAMILIES AND SENIORS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE HAVE ANY LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION- TO MAKE SURE THAT
PROPERTY OWNERS CAN CONTINUE
PROVIDING HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
TO. OVER SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE. THANKS FOR THE
TIME AND THANK YOU AND THE WORK
THAT YOU ALL HAVE DONE AND
THANKS TO THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO
OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU. WELL
NOW GO TO THE LINE. TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER MINER AND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAMBERS THIS IS ROSS BARKLEY
WITH THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINETY ONE
THANKS. NOW GO TO LINE
FOURTEEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ADAM UNIONIST ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY PUBLIC WATER AGENCY- JUST
WANT TO COMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
ON YOUR SWIFT ACTION ON THIS
ISSUE AS YOU PROBABLY HEARD IN
THE NEWS THE STATE WATER BOARD
ESTIMATES THAT APPROXIMATELY-
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS
OWED FOR DRINKING WATER BILLS-
SO WE APPRECIATE THE FUNDING
PROPOSED IN THESE MEASURES AND
IT IT'S A GREAT START- BUT AS
WE HEARD THIS MORNING THE
PRIORITY FOCUS IF THESE BILLS
ARE RENTAL REPAYMENTS. AND WE
AGREE WITH THAT- WE UNDERSTAND
THAT APPRECIATE THAT HOWEVER WE
FEEL THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
GOING TO BE NEEDED THAT IS
FOCUSED ON HELPING CUSTOMERS
COVER THE DEBT OF UTILITY
BILLS- WHICH IS GOING TO BE
SIGNIFICANT SO OUR MEMBERS HAVE
CONTINUED TO PROVIDE SERVICE
DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT FEDERAL
AND STATE ASSISTANCE IS NEEDED.
IN THIS EMERGENCY SITUATION FOR
SMALL MEDIUM AND LARGE SYSTEMS-
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
EFFORTS ON THIS- AND- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. WELL NOW
GO THE LINE TWENTY FOUR ONE
TWENTY FOUR THE MONEY'S NOT
THERE. THANK YOU THIS TIME IT
WILL BE A CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION- I JUST WANT TO
TOUCH ON A FEW ITEMS GRAYSON-
THERE TENANTS WHO ARE ABOUT THE
DEEPEST RESPECT YEAH MY
THRESHOLD COVERED BY THE
ACTIONS OF THREE ZERO EIGHT AND
THIS BILL. COULD NOT PAID WENT
LAST YEAR WHEN THEY COULD AND
SHOULD HAVE STAYED IN THE
BETTER DOLLARS IN THIS PROGRAMS
NOT COVERED THE SITUATION WE
BELIEVE THAT TECHNOLOGY BRIDGES
THE GAP AND- THE MEN OF THE
FOLDERS THAT TENANTS ARE NOT
COMMUNICATING WITH THEM AND
ACCORDING TO SEVERAL OTHER KIND
OF MUST FIND THE APPLICATION.
FOR LABOR TO THE ARREARS AGAIN
NO NEED STATE HELP. HELP TO AS
WELL. THE MONEY NEEDS YEAH
QUICKLY TOP TEN AND THEN.
BALDUR'S WHO THAT WAS FOR- OVER
A YEAR. WIENER THE IMPORTANCE.
AND WE ARE NEUTRAL BUT- WE
STILL HAVE MUCH TO DO. THE
DALLAS APARTMENT. STANDS READY.
TO LANDLORDS AND TENANTS I
WOULD NEED TO APPLY FOR THANK
YOU. NOW DO TELL MY. TWO EIGHT.
HI THIS IS PATRICK WHAT PRETTY
MINUTES PLEASE THIRTY I WANTED
TO A THE COMMITTEE THE HEARING
AND PER THE FOR RAISING
QUESTION ABOUT HOW. ME RECEIVED
LAND TO. ANYWAY REPRESENT THE
INTERESTS OF PUBLICLY OWNED
ELECTRIC UTILITIES AND PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON SB NINETY
ONE BUT AGAIN WE WANT TO
EXPRESS APPRECIATION- THAT
WOULD KILL THE- A REAR GATE ARE
IN CONSIDERATION UNDER THE
LEGISLATION. IS THAT POSITIVE
START TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE
HOWEVER IF YOU USE PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES THEIR CUSTOMERS HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF DETAIL
THE THAT COVERING A BROAD RANGE
OF CUSTOMER CLASSES THE
COMMERCIAL CUSTOMERS AND
HOMEOWNERS AS WELL. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
MINISTRATION FURTHER ON THIS
ISSUE TO ADDRESS SAYS RARE KIDS
AT OUR MEMBERS THAT YOU MIGHT
MEMBERS CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEIR CUSTOMERS I TO ADDRESS
THOSE UNPAID BILLS AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELL NOW
GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE ONE
TWENTY NINE ONE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS KEVIN INFO FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION-
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORTER
PROTECTING TENANTS AND SB
EIGHTY NINE AND SB NINETY ONE
THANK YOU. NOW WITH A TWO LINE.
TWENTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS SHELLY TOO LONG AND I
AM THE PARENT OF A YOUNG WOMAN
WHO HAS DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES I'M ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CHANCE
HOUSING WHICH IS A COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFIT AGENCY-
PROVIDING HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
INCLUDING. AT PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. I'M
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE- I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND LEGISLATURE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THESE BILLS AND-
FOR THE EVICTION PROTECTIONS
BUT ALSO THE STATE ASSISTANCE
TO LANDLORDS AND TENANTS AND
FOR UTILITIES. I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THESE BILLS IN THEIR PROVISIONS.
AS AN AGENCY I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE STATE TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAMS IN THE
COMMUNITY THEY ARE SO CRITICAL
TO CALIFORNIANS WITH
DISABILITIES. INCLUDING TENANTS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
THANK YOU THIS. NOW GO TO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS KATHY ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY CALLING IN SUPPORT WITH
CONCERN ON SB EIGHTY NINE AT
THE NINETY ONE WHAT WE ARE
GRATEFUL IN SUPPORT OF THE
URGENT WORK AND EXTENDING THE
MORATORIUM AND THAT THE BILL
THE MONEY RENTAL THAT FOR SOME
TENANTS. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO EXTEND THE
QUALITY TO ALL TENANTS
INCLUDING AND IF ECESSARY BY
USING OUR SURPLUS GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS I DRAFTING THIS BILL
MAYBE POLITICAL KIND OF AT THE
MERCY OF LANDLORDS EMPLOYERS
AND BILL COLLECTORS MISSING
BALANCE IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL BUT WE
STILL HAVE COME TO EXPECT. AND
IT MUST BE DONE PROPERLY LASTLY
WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FAILURE TO INCLUDE THE
VOICES OF TENANTS AND THE LACK
OF OVERSIGHT HEARING TO FINE
TUNE ITSELF BECAUSE WE KNOW
THIS WILL HAVE TO BE DEALT WITH
AGAIN IN JUNE IT PERCENT SO
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT
TENANTS IN CRACKING THE VERY
NEXT VERSION OF THIS BILL. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO DOING. THAT
WORK THANK YOU SO MUCH. NOW TO
LINE. ONE THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THAT MOIRA TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANDY
ECHO I WANT STRONG SUPPORT OF-
THE MEASURE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON QUICKLY
DRAFTING AND PUTTING THE SPELL.
OUT TO- HELP OUR CONSTITUENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE NOW GO LIVE.
SEVENTEEN YES- GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CREAM GREASY
BUT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS NOT GIVEN THAT WE
ARE IN THE MIDST OF A PANDEMIC
C. R. IS NEUTRAL ON SB EIGHTY
NINE SB NINETY ONE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE RENTAL
HOUSING PROVIDERS REMAIN ABOVE
WATER YOU CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED HOUSING
TENANTS ACROSS THE STATE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I'LL GO TO LINE.
TWENTY GOOD MORNING CARE
NUMBERS BRIAN A GUSTO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ONE
ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH
COMMENTS OF OUR COLLEAGUES AT
WESTERN CENTER AMMAN POVERTY ON
THE NEED TO. AFTER THIS BILL
CONTINUE TO WORK. ON THE FIXES
AND DIDN'T ENGAGE IN A PROCESS
THAT THAT PUTS IT TENANTS ARE
MOST. AFFECTED BY THIS AT THE
TABLE IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING OUT
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. HOUSING
MOVE TOWARDS THE NEXT ELECTION
CLIP ON JUNE THIRTIETH. THANK
YOU. SURE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
CUED UP TO ASK. OPERATE
PROMINENTLY ON. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHILE WE
WAIT TO SEE IF ANYBODY ELSE
COMES ON THE PHONE LINE I KNOW
MISS MISS ERIC LEVY HAD A-
ANSWER TO DOCTOR WHAT'S
QUESTIONS SO IF SHE'S STILL ON
THE LINE. SAM YEAH YOU CAN GO
AHEAD S. B. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY YES I'M A DOCTOR
WOULD AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MATHIS AND FONG HAD QUESTIONS
IN REGARDS TO THE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION CARVE OUT. FOR
SMALL. ENTITIES AND I JUST
WANTED TO CONFIRM THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION THE 10% OR UP TO
TEN PERCENT. ADMIN COMES OFF
BEFORE- OF THE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IS DISTRIBUTED TO ALL
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION WILL
GO TOWARDS PROGRAM. FOR SMALL-
JURISDICTION. IN HERE. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE LINE. OKAY HERE NO ONE ELSE
IS QUEUED UP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I ALSO JUST WANTED TO
ANNOUNCE THAT THERE WAS A
BUDGET HEARING SCHEDULED FOR
TOMORROW THAT HAS BEEN CANCELED.
BUDGET HEARING TOMORROW HAS
BEEN CANCELED SO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS WE ARE GONNA
TURN.